我是王熙
那个首先的话一周过得非常的快啊
然后这一周的话就是啊
应该来讲是我们压力很大的一周
待会再跟大家讲
为什么压力很大
那首先的话呢很开心啊
上一周我们决定要给大家送我们的T恤
有的同学说我们是不是以讲课为名
实际上走上了带货的道路啊
这个帽子贴的还是挺好的
我们可以考虑一下
将来以后我们要不要靠卖T恤为生对吧
支撑我们开games104这门课的这个经费
毕竟我司经费很紧张
然后的话呢然后呢因为这个要给大家发T恤
就骗了大家很多的社区
你的留言
然后就发现哇都是人才啊
我觉得特别有意思
我这里面选几个比较好玩的
比如说有同学告诉我们说现在自己是准妈妈
然后的话呢
正好利用这个假期去这个学104课程
这就是算法胎教对吧
我们游戏引擎算法胎教
还有同学说哎我们就是哎呀这个设什么来着
不好意思说那个词了
我们叫社会人吧啊说说实话确实是这样的
因为我已没有当过老师
所以我就是个程序员
那我就把我自己写程序遇到的所有的痛苦啊
包括我发现我不懂的知识就跟大家一起去分享
所以相对来讲就比较真实一点
比较实战一点
然后很有意思的一个同学跟我们讲
说
他那个开始学104肢的时候啊
还是一个在学校里面有毕业这个课程
上着上着
现在已经变成了社会青年一枚了
所以的话呢
就是说我觉得其实社区的同学们反馈
真的很好玩啊
还有人说要把很多我们游戏引擎的黑化
打印到我们的这个就是这个T恤上来
对此处的话
我觉得我们我们get的这个商机的点子了对吧
我们后面的话就继续走在这个什么
以课程为为名卖T恤的这个不归路上
继续往前走
那么接下来就跟大家隆重的宣布
我们就是我们的T恤最后选择的是什么对吧
那此处应该有什么当当当的效果音了
但实际上的话在B站上
同学们已经看到我们投票的结果了
其实两款T恤的这个就是选择是非常的接近的
真的说明什么说明都很好看
真的我自己也是很难挑的
我两个都想要
那么最后的话大家选择了我们的第一款
那么这里面的话呢
就是说
希望同学们在我们每一节课的后面去留言
然后呢
我们每一节课我会选十个我们的幸运的同学来
我们会把T恤送给大家
到目前为止的话
我们还没有任何的商业计划
怎么去卖这个T恤
我们都不知道怎么去收费
所以我们只能采取送的方式送给大家
那就是其实非常喜欢
就是同学们那个跟我们一起玩一起互动的
这也是我们104的精神
我觉得真的有一个地方
就是让大家一起很开心的去一起学一些
我们觉得感兴趣的东西
因为真的创造这样的一个虚拟世界的感受
真的很快乐
非常的快乐
包括我这次准备我们这节课的时候
我一直在说
哇真的很好玩
太太有意思了
我恨不得马上就去写代码了
所以其实呢我们从社区里面
其实真的有的时候蛮感动的
比如说啊有些同学他不会在社区里发音
但是他会给我们发那个笔记
他们自己会把每一节课的东西记下来
然后我看了之后
我觉得哇太棒了
我一直在想说
我们花了这么大的心血准备了104的课程
将来以后能不能把它整理成一本书
这样的话就把我们说的内容整理成册
这样方便大家去看
那这也是我们后面可以想做的很多
有意思的事情
而且就是说我觉得这真的就是社区的感觉吧
那我们为此呢
就是我们稍后我们的课程组小伙伴们商量
就是我们专门申请了一个新的邮箱
这个邮箱的话
你就大家如果有一些就是课程相关的
一些就是非public的问题的话
比如说你做了一些有意思的建议呀
或者是一些好的这种笔记啊
大家可以发到这个邮箱里面
扣了引擎专用的邮箱里面就发给我们
然后的话呢我们这边的话
同学们的话如果看到了
就是诶我们可以做什么的话
会给大家一些反馈
反正就是说我们这个community
对我们来讲是其实是最重要的
然后最后呢就是回答一下同学们的一些问题吧
我们发现这个这个星期的话
同学们的问题还是蛮多的
第一个同学问我问题
就是说啊这个问题其实是蛮蛮蛮
怎么说呢
我觉得蛮黑暗的对吧
就是老头环里面
这个AI去读了这个玩家的书对吧
据说有rumor是这么讲的呢
这个玩意儿到底算不算AI未来主流的发展方向
那说实话呢
这个从就是真正的就是叫经典教育上的游戏
AI来讲的话
我们会认为他是作弊的
因为很简单嘛
就是游戏AI的核心的一个
就是我们叫做一个啊叫道德规范
就是说你不能够超越玩家获取额外的信息
否则你的那个行为看上去就是啊作弊的
就像我们比如说我们做啊cs的AI的话
我们不会说让AI知道整个地图
你必须是你能看见一个什么人
你只能通过你听到的脚步声
这样的话那个AI体的行为才像是我们的期待的
这个就是人工智能体的行为
但是的话呢其实对于那种就是说动作打击
交互要求很敏感的这样的一些AI bot的话
确实你如果只是从玩玩家的这个最后的行为
比如说同他的位移啊
从它的位置变化
你去反向推导它的intention的话呢
这件事情确实是很难的
如果你真实做过AI的话
就知道这件事情非常难
所以作为一个practice
就是说作为一个游戏研发者的话
我认为就是老头环的这个选择是完全合理
可以接受的
因为这样会让他的AI更加的灵敏
更加的反应敏捷
其实是增加了我们的游戏乐趣
但是不是所有的游戏AI都这么做的话
那我认为这道大可不必
比如说我们做个RTS游戏的话
我不要读对吧
玩家每一秒的这个双击操作
因为你做RTS游戏
大家知道就是我有大量的无效的点击
对不对
我就是手手抖
抖得很开心
我就点了
你怎么样嘛对吧
那这个时候我要把这些input
放进我的AI体系里面的话
那肯定AI就疯掉了
都不知道你要干什么了对吧
所以的话这是我的观点
那么第二个的话
有同学问我们说
这个AI计算机的游戏引擎
到底给多大的budget啊
这个问题其实啊是一个怎么说呢
我认为是一个呃仁者见仁
智者见智的问题
因为根据你不同类型的游戏产品来讲的话
我们给AIF的budget其实真的不一样
你比传统的我们会给AI大概比如说一毫秒
2ms的计算时间
对不对
但是实际上如果你这个游戏的话
它就是一个策略游戏
打个比方
我是一个呃很复杂的一个那个
比如说turn base的strategy game
就是回合制的策略游戏
它你有一个很大的世界
需要你模拟你上百个君主的这种行为
那么这个AI的话我就可以把这个给的高一点
让他大量的去进行精细的计算
让这些那个那个就是说每一个NPC的王国的
那些君主的行为看上去很像人类一点对吧
那这个我的AI的bug就可以的非常的高
那么这里面做A我讲了之后
大家就能想象到什么什么游戏了
对不对
什么著名的什么什么社对吧
他们的很多游戏好像跟这个都有点像
但是的话呢如果比如说比较real time
比如说像我们的
比如说这种射击游戏啊
或者是更快的这种设计
应该已经非常快了嘛
那其实我们有的时候会给AI的8G的
相对小一点
比如像单机游戏里面
有的时候啊我们的AI体数量并不是特别多的话
我们的bug呢点的呢
对于每个单个的AIK的会比较高
所以你会发现
其实为什么你们打网游的时候
经常会发现很多AI显得有点笨
但是你玩单机游戏的时候
你会发现AI很聪明
那实际上的话就是预算给的是不一样的
所以呢包括像这里面有一个小细节
就是同学们如果做AI系统的时候
他的ticking并不需要每秒钟30帧
60帧
它跟rendering是彻底的分离掉的
所以AI可以相对低频的进行更新
比如说一秒钟几次问题也不是很大
甚至有一些比较复杂的运算
你一秒钟更新一次策略也问题不是很大
所以的话呢就是说真实的一个游戏引擎
AI系统的话呢
它的架构实际上是分很多层的
然后有一些更宏观的东西
我会低频一点的更新它
有些这个就是啊低调的东西
我会高频的更新它
而且呢这个后面会讲的
就是说其实很多的算法可以混合着用的好的
然后第三个问题的话
同学们就问我们说这个就是说稍等啊
我看看就是能不能用分布式的这个系统
把AI从客户端把它分离出去
就因为AI里面做那个客户端里面做AI很费嘛
我能不能比如说把它放到服务器上
甚至放到云上去做这件事情
其实在现代的游戏里面
已经是很多的一个实践了
practice了
比如说在很多的网游里面
我们已经可以把AI变成一个
独立的这样的一个服务器了
就AI服务器对吧
包括像那个pitch这种东西已经很成熟
那我们完全可以把AI
直接预购于我们的游戏引擎之外
它就变成一个服务在那
然后呢我通过Python接口去调用它都可以
所以这个事情呢
我认为是未来的一个比较大的一个发展方向
但是呢这个也很难以一言以蔽之
因为什么呢
比如说我们假设玩一个手游
那手游它所有的计算
它就在那个小小的那个那个那个那个方寸之间
那么你可能就要用手游自身的那个
就是AI推理芯片对吧
所以的话呢但是呢对于一个复杂的
比如说多人的mm或者是一个网上的虚拟世界
我们确实是可以把很多AI变成一个独立的服务
那这里面的话呢就是这肯定是它的好处
因为这样的话
我的AI可以做的非常的丰富和复杂
但是呢他带来的坏处是什么呢
因为AI能计算它有个很大的前提是什么
我们前面的课程讲的叫我要做perception
什么意思
就是说我要不断的从当前的这个世界里面
抓取各种各样的状态对吧
那这些状态从各个世界里抓取出来
然后呢
通过比如说网络那个transfer
到我的AI的server的话
这个过程其实是比较废的
就是有的时候你计算本身可能还可以
但是你把这些这个perception的这些data
就what state status
就是世界的状态那个packaging
然后serialize到DISCIALIZED到我的AI服务器
可能有的时候是很麻烦
而且如果你是分布式的AI服务器的话
我还得同时穿很多很多份
但这个事情的话呢
就是这都是一个balance
就是说如果你的AI的计算本身真的是足够
expensive的话
我们认为这件事情还是值的
你要是问我
大家问我个人的观点的话呢
我我会比较喜欢这种架构
因为这种架构的话
它很符合我们做引擎架构的一个叫decoupling的
一个一个一个原则
就是说我把各种那个就是说计算变成一种服务
那这个每个服务它都是独立的maintain
足系的独立的维护
他彼此之间的话是通过一个数据协议去交换
这样的话大家想象一下
如果对于一个超复杂的一个虚拟世界的架构造
来讲的话
比如说某个AI服务器坏了对吧
那我的游戏还在玩怎么办
诶我可以重新再起一下这个服务
把这个东西再pick up
把整个链接全部建立起来
那这样的一个架构
它是不是一个很鲁棒的架构呢对吧
所以我个人是很pro这个方向了
所以我觉得问这个问题的同学应该是蛮专业的
因为这是个很专业向的一个问题
好OK那就是今天的话呢
我就挑了几个问题跟大家去回答一下
其实这个问题是我们课程组
课程组的小伙伴们挑的
但是我觉得他们挑的质量真的很好
OK好
那接下来的话呢
就回到我们今天的课程的主题了
叫什么这个高级的AI系统对吧
这个也是我们这一次这个跟大家准备的很久的
这门这个这个这个section就是AIAIAI好
那其实呢实话实说啊
这一节课准备的啊
它的惨烈程度远远超过了我们的想象
就是本来不是说我们AI本来只讲一节课
然后我们准备了一个180页的PPT
后来我们把最后的大概40页到50页摘出来
说我们单独讲吧
因为一节课实在讲不下去
然后等我们开始再去准备
这一节课的内容的时候
发现它又涨到了150页
160页的PPT
而且的话呢我又内心产生了一个冲动
我说哎要不要把这个AI分成两趴
一趴
我们就讲一些传统的
比如说HTN啊
GP啊
这些方法
包括蒙特卡罗方法
然后deep learning单独再去讲一讲一他
但是这个告诉大家一个坏消息
最后我还是克制住我的冲动了
因为实在是干不动了
所以呢我们这次今天的课程密度会非常的大
就是我们会在一节课的时间里面把从传统的
比如说HTN呐
GP这些方法
然后呢
再讲到A蒙特卡罗的蒙特卡洛树的搜索的方法
然后再给大家讲a machine learning
那实话实说啊
我这节课准备到后来
我的状态是什么状态呢
就是呃我写到就是我合到后面的PPT了
我已经忘了我前面在说什么了
包括我今天在上课之前的话
我在整个过这个PPT
我发现我已经忘了好多东西了
就是那一页我到底在讲什么东西
所以同学们如果在课程中发现
我已经开始神情恍惚
然后开始去找我
为什么要写这些PPT的时候
请大家提前给我一个免死金牌
因为确实这个感觉是好几个不同的universe
我们在一起来回的跳跃
但是没关系对吧
我们games104的课程是什么
就是互相比干嘛对吧
我们就是这个内卷到卷到极致
所以今天我们开卷好
那今天我们就卷一个比较硬核的
这个就是高级的AI系统
怎么去做呢
首先的话呢我们来个开胃小菜叫HTM
就是说层次任务网络对吧
就是hierarchical task network
那这个东西呢实际上大家在上一节课
我们学过什么
我们学过behavior tree对吧
行为数
行为数其实真的是个很好的东西啊
而且我对他的感情非常深
因为我以前是在BANGESTUDENT
我今天穿的就是halo reach的这个这个T恤对吧
然后的话呢那那个时候呢
biai tree当时也算是班级给行业做了一个贡献
那么好
you try其实很好
但是呢它有没有问题
其实它有一个很有趣的小问题
就是说当我们的设计师在一个一个的构建内
一个个的节点
比如说selector a sequencer对吧
我就依次规划我的行为
其实它更像是一个就是反应机器
叫reaction machine
什么意思
就是说当这个世界给我各种各样的输出的时候
我要做出各种各样的反应
它更像就像我们讲的
就是我是一个呃
怎么说呢
我是一个无脑的条件反射的
像巴甫洛夫这样的一那只狗
我看见了闻到了什么东西
我就做出以下几个动作
但是我们的人类的行为实际上什么是consciousness
就是我们有意识的
那意识最重要的是什么呢
就是我要有一个主观意图对吧
我想让我自己变得更好
我为什么要健身
因为我想让自己的这个身材更好一点
我其实是有一个目标的好
实际上当我们的设计师在构建那个
behavior tree的时候
你看着他做的是一个一个节点的展开
但其实他更多的是说
我希望这个AI能够完成这么一件事对吧
他能保护好自己
他能够成为这个战场上最猛的那个AI
能够让所有人都恐惧它
它它是有够的
那这个时候其实在hierarchy
就是大家就会发现
be AI tree实际上是有一个很大的一个局限性
就是它不直观
但是今天大家如果真的去看一个
be AI税的这样的一个编辑器的时候
你会发现大家会做很多事情
在上面打个框
上面写个注释
说哎我这一棵子树是做什么用的
这个时候是通过什么方式表达的
是通过注释的方式告诉大家说
你别看我这边一会儿用selector
一会用sequence
但实际上我做的一件事情
就是说确保我的这个啊NPC不会饿死
或者确保我的NPC不会这个中毒之后
他自己知道把自己治疗的好对吧
我是有够的
那么HTN的话呢
实际上就是从另外一个角度来解决这个问题
他是从这个任务目标出发的
那么HD这个东西呢其实用的人其实蛮多的
就是说比如像最新的那个horizon对吧
像这个就是说啊这个duck so对吧
这些大作产品都用了HTN这样的一个架构
那HN的话它的核心思想是什么呢
其实就像人类一样去做一个计划
比如说今天我要去这个学一个东西
就是我要去学一门课
那我首先做一件什么事情呢
我首先要去查资料对吧
我的第一步我要准备学习资料
那这个时候呢
他首先是他要把我要上这门课的东西
分解成好几部
第一个就是诶我要去准备资料对吧
我要到这个教室
我要开始学习
然后呢我要去在课程之后回答很多问题
做一些q and a
你看这是不是很科学合理
对不对好
那我在这个准备这个学习资料的时候呢
其实我的选择有很多
对不对
我可以去选择去图书馆查资料
我也可以上网去冲浪查资料
所以这里面我们会出现一个selecting的过程
所以你看这个行为是不是很像一个behavior tree
对吧
但是它的整个这个寓意感是完全不一样的
就是包括这一棵树状结构的东西
大家理解起来其实非常符合人类的知觉
这就相当于是说
我们对任何一个AI体的行为的话
我们把它表述表述成若干个我要完成的任务
以及为了完成这个任务
我需要完成多种的子任务
包括每个子任务有哪些选项
这样的逻辑就清楚了
那么HTN的框架是什么样子的呢
实际上它基本上你可以翻成这么几大块
第一块呢就是叫一个叫worst days
就是这个世界的状态
还有一个什么呢
感知器
感知器呢非常像我们之前讲的这个perception
这个地方我是真的是要小小的吐槽一下
就是这两个名词呢
实际上是作者就是原文你们定义的这个东西
但是说实话这两个东西都非常的confusing
比如说worth state
我自己的感觉
就是我觉得初学者特别容易犯的
一个错误是什么呢
就是说大家会觉得worth state
是对世界的这个状态的一个真实的描述
比如说哎这个我面前有几个敌人呢对吧
这个战场的情况
比如说我在这个关卡什么阶段呢
包括我自己的这个血量
但实际上这里的worst days
并不是真正的一个客观的世界的一个表达
是一个主观
就是在我AI体的大脑里面
我对这个世界认知
你看这个做这个书算法的老哥
我感觉是有点哲学性思维的
就是说我们在那个就是在学哲学理论的时候
不是有一个叫什么主观唯心主义是吧
什么客观唯唯物主义嘛
对不对
主观唯心主义认为什么呢
认为整个世界都是假的
都是在我的大脑里面
就是我就是我的认知里面构造了逐这个世界
它让我怀让我相信外面有个客观世界的存在
但这都是一个幻想
你看这么深奥深奥的哲学原理
就这么偷偷摸摸的
就塞到了HTN的架构里面了
而这个地方是特别容易犯错的
就是说其实worst并不是真实世界的访问
而是在这个AIT大脑里面
他对这个世界的一些关键要素的一个一个思想
或者是一个一个提炼
那么sensor呢更像是perception
就是他负责从游戏的整个环境里面
抓取各种各样的状态
这两个概念一定要分得很清楚
因为待会再算算法的时候
他他俩就会起作用
那么接下来的话呢
就是说在这个TM的这个框架里面的话呢
我们有一个就是那个H键多M
这个多面里面的话呢
其实放的就是一个我们的很多的就是层次化的
像树状结构的task以及它之间的关联关系
这个待会展开
然后呢
当他这个就是树状task全部在里面规划好之后
根据现在就是AIT看看到的这个
他感知到了这个世界的状态
然后呢他会做一个计划
比如说我会当然了
我首先会选择一个task
比如说我的task是上课堂
那我接下来就会规划
我要做12345很多的这个task这个事件
这些task就是通过一个planner把它放到这
就make a plan
当你的一个plan有了之后
接下来有一个就是plan那个runner
他就会依次的执行这个task
但这里面有个细节
就是说我们做好一个计划
我们去执行它的时候是不会一帆风顺
应该不会对吧
中间比如说整个世界会发生很多变化
或者说我高估了自己的能力
比如说我觉得我三天可以学完高等数学
想想哎呀
等我考试前学到第二天的时候
明天后天就要考试了
其实我已经放弃了
因为我觉得高数这门课算了
我放弃吧
对不对哦
我在我在我在大学的时候
我经常是这样子
我最后三天准备一门考试
但是学到第二天的时候
我觉得啊算了
我放弃治疗了
这门课学分我不要了对吧
那其实TX在执行之后
你自己也会产生很多的问题
比如说血量不允许了
对不对
你本来觉得你可以干掉那个小怪
但是呢这个时候突然背后冒出了一个小怪
他背后射了你一箭
你血量其实已经不够了
你本来觉得你能干得过他
但你干不过他
对不对
那这个时候实际上ta runner
它会监控所有在执行的这个task的状态
如果发现你干不了的时候
诶他会告诉你
接下来会启动另外一个课程
后面会详细的展开去讲
叫做replay好
所以同学们的话首先理解这个HTN
它是这么一个架构
这个架构很有用
因为待会我会跟大家去讲另外一个算法叫GP
就是面向那个目标的这样的一个优化算法的话
其实这个架构这两个架构非常的接近
那么这个时候诶我们怎么去构建这个事件呢
那你首先要构建的东西是什么呢
是task任务到底是什么
在HTN里面的话呢
它定义了两种task
第一种task叫primitive task
它是最简单的用task
它更多的就是一个动作
而第二种呢我们叫做compound task
叫符合任务
符合任务的话
它其实是HTN的核心破
它或者是它的精华好
我们先讲最简单的这个primitive task
那么这种原子形的这种任务啊
它跟我们之前halo trade里面的话
有一些小小的不同
大家还记得我们在别墅区里面的话
我们并没有强制要求说每一个立业节点
我一定会给他加一个precondition
对不对对吧
包括我们一个动作做完之后
对世界有什么影响呢
其实在B车里面并没有明确的去讲
对不对
但是在这个就是HTN里面的话
我们每个premiere task
我们实际上是有三个关键要素的
第一个当然是你动作本身
动作本身怎么办呢
你写个脚本执行也好
写个什么执行都好对吧
但是你要给你的这个动作要加一个precondition
就是说你在你的word里面哪些state满足了我的条件
哎我这个task才会真的去执行
否则的话我会返回一个force
第二个这个task执行中间的话
我肯定也有可能会失败
并不是所有task他一定会成功
虽然你就算所有的PREGENTATION全部满足了
这一点大家一定要注意诶
最后做完之后我呢还会去修改这个世界的状态
对不对
我做了动作的目的
为什么不就是改造世界嘛
对不对
所以当我们去构建一个HTN的网络的时候呢
哎我们这三个东西要素一定要有
这三个要素呢其实是有妙用的
但是呢这里面大家注意一个事
就是它的前置条件
它其实是对stage的一个毒的操作
就世界状态的一个毒的操作
对不对
那么effect或者叫EFFECTURE
就修改就叫修改器的话呢
它是对这个世界的一个反向的一个写的操作
这里面举一个例子
比如说我们第一个print task就是这个啊
我们要用这个解药对吧
那它的前提是什么呢
我首先要有一瓶解药对吧
那我最后如果这个用解药
就是我这个喝完这个解药这个动作成功了之后
我对世界的修改是什么呢
诶第一个
我现在这个我的这个这个
这个就是说我的解中毒的状态
会被我解消解除掉
对不对
第二个呢很悲催的是
我的那个解读药水数量得减个一
你看这个是不是很简单对吧
那么包括就是说诶
我们假设用一个超强的这样一个解药的话
我们会发现
就是说第一我首先要确保这个药物是有的对吧
但是呢哎我这个万能药我用完之后
首先我万能药很悲催的要减掉一个对吧
但是呢我无论是被中毒了呀
还是被这个什么sleeping玩家
这个状态我全部给解掉对吧
你看很简单吧
但是的话你会发现就是刚才刚才我们讲的
就是说PREGNITION是读取世界的一个状态
确保我这个动作是最基础的条件是能满足的
我能执行的这个动作
假设执行真的成功了之后
我会去写这个世界
这跟我们人类一样的
我们人类perception感知世界
然后我的consciousness
我的主主观意识让我做出很多行为
但我的这些行为最后产生的结果是什么
我们又会改造这个世界对吧
否则的话这个世界就太无聊了嘛
一定是要我们来改造的嘛
好那primitive task就很好理解了
那接下来就来了一个最有趣的了
就是哎符合任务
其实符合任务啊
他我觉得一个最简单的一个解释是什么呢
就是首先首先跟他讲原书上的定义啊
他就讲说哎一个符合任务呢
他首先是有很多的method构成的
那么每个message有一个一组precondition
就是那这个method的
其实他从上到下本身暗含的是什么呢
叫priority
就是说当我一个任务过来的时候
我每一个message
你可以认为完成这个任务的一种方案对吧
那么我有三种不同的方案
那最后我会让你优先的选择第一种对吧
如果第一种的precondition不满足的话
不好意思
那你就选择第二种吧
对不对
如果第二种不满足的话
那你就尝试第三种呗
那么如果三种你都不满足怎么办
我就算我失败了呗
所以这里面是个什么东西呢
大家如果回想一下
上节课你看隔了一个星期
其实说实话我已经忘了
但我希望同学们不要忘了
就是上节课我们讲了什么
讲了behavior tree对吧
halo里面那个东西叫什么叫selector
对不对
那其实就component task里面的
它的method之间的话
它更像是构建了一个selector
诶
更有意思的东西就来了
他每个method叫我完成这个task的任务
我们完成这个task5的方法
实际上呢它不是指向一个单一的task
它可以放一串task
那为什么他要放1tron task呢
这个是什么呢
就是说哎我这个完成这个任务的目标啊
其实我要做很多次任务
这些子任务你必须要依次成功地执行完
我这个方法才是真的成立的
诶这个地方像什么东西了
是不是很像我们上behavior tree里面讲的
那个叫sequencer对吧
依次执行
所以其实你去理解他的common task
就是有的时候你就觉得很生气啊
你说你写HDN的文章的老哥
你非定义了这些东西
如果你给我做一个behavior trade analogy的话
我不就秒懂了吗
说实话我当时读那个paper
我读的很透很透的
我们团队讨论了半天啊
就大家就是各种细节的讨论
但最后的结论是他两个东西
它就是一个这个selector
再加上一个sequencer
形成了一个组合
当然这里面肯定不一定准确
还是有很多细微的差别
但是呢作为大家去理解这个符合任务的话
这个大概也明白了
说你很多后面的算法你就大致能看得明白
但是我这边要提醒大家
就是说真的同学们实现一个自己的HTN的话
还是有很多小细节了
大家千万别为我这个就是简单的类比
给带到坑里面去了
好那么这个逻辑的话呢
实际上我们去看这个就是诶
我们构建刚才那个案例里面
是不是变得很简单了
比如说我想要解读的这个任务
那我首先就问说啊
你有两个选择
看见要我就先喝解药
我就先喝下去
但是说实话这个我们都是小气的人对吧
那我首先干嘛呢
我优先看看我能不能造出药
这样的话减少我要的损失对吧
所以呢我的第一个选项就是诶
我是不是有足够的材料
如果有足够的材料
我干嘛我开始造谣啊
那怎么去造药呢
我的我的
我的这个方法里面的第一个task是什么呢
Make a portion
就是我先造解药
那造解药的话呢
就是哎你以为你的挑战
其实这个地方写的不够严谨啊
实际上make a potion
那个power
前面preparation还可以再去check一下你的材料够不够
这个时候哎如果我材料够的时候
我把材料给它剪掉
然后呢哎我的药数量就会增加
第二步是什么呢
诶我来去use a portion对吧
就是我首先再次确认一下我是有药的
然后呢接下来我把我的状态
整个我假设我的喝完药水之后
这个动作做完之后
那我的状态肯定会恢复吗
对不对
然后我的破损数量减一嘛
但是呢如果这个时候诶
我第二个选项哦
这讲错了
第二个选项是什么呢
我实在没有材料怎么办呢
我去买一个破损对吧
你看这个这个这个NPC是很小气的
他身上有药水
死活不用
他
首先是要么去造
要么去买
实在不行才用自己的好
这个时候我就去买
那买的话呢
我的我展开的第一个方法
就是说我先去买一个portion
然后我才去用它
但这里面再展开就很多的细节了
大家会发现诶
实际上用这种方法去展开一个行为
书的话
展开一个行为
就是这个这个NPC行为的时候
是不是非常符合人的这种直观的理解
这也是我个人觉得
我对HTN的一个很好感的一个地方
就是说他确实就是非常方便
就是设计师去构筑他自己的逻辑体系
因为别说去的话
包括我们之前跟设计师一起讨论的时候
会发现
其实理解和陪
就是大家训练起来还是比较抽象的
很多人是要花很多时间去理解
就是这为什么我用怎么用selector sequencer
去构建一个比较合理的逻辑
20天的话
在我的理解中更像是把这个东西直接打包了
你呢就不用理解什么select a sequencer
你就理解成就是单一任务
就是原子任务和复合任务
原复合任务里面它它永远只有这一个策略
就是你有一组的选项
你可以优先选择谁
选择之后
那接下来你就12345
依次完成这个任务就完了
那么之间它到底是用selector还是用sequencer
这些抽象的名词
你就不用去记了
因为其实理解select sequence
这两个抽象名词本身也是很费时间的好
这就是我们这个HTM的两大
这个这个就是HDMDM
就是我们DM就是它最核心的这个这个空间里面
两两大核心
这个这个这个怪神兽
一个叫primitive task
一个叫compound task
那其实这个时候我们有了这两大神兽之后
我们就可以这个构建就像零一样的
我们用零一就可以构建整个HTM的这个DAI
就是它的空间
那么这里面的话呢
有唯一一个特殊的东西是什么呢
哎我们需要把一个task定义成一个叫root task
就是我的根节点的task
那所谓的root task其实想想也是很简单的
就是说一大概率他应该是一个component task
对吧
是一个符合task
然后他就定义了我作为一个
比如说我作为一个精英小怪
我最核心的几大行为是什么
我作为一个精英小怪
我首先是要砍人的
对不对
但是呢如果我血量不行不行了
比如说我中毒了怎么办
我得救自己对吧
如果我看见一个一个一个老哥
我打不过怎么办
我得逃
对不对
然后实在不行
如果什么敌人也没有对吧
我也没什么状态干嘛
我在那得闲晃对吧
所以说其实root task他是核心的
就是是非常方便我们的设计师的理解
就是我从最high level去定义
我的这个老哥的几个关键行为
然后呢你再一次一次的把它展开
直接涨
一直展开到什么呢
Premium task
所以说呢HTN的这个网络的话
就是其实那个树看上去蛮干净的
蛮好看的好
那么其实呢就以刚才那个为例的话
比如说我们一个就是小怪的行为
他首先是什么诶
首先确保自己的活命
所以首先如果发现我中毒了
我首先优先保证自己不要被这个中毒了
如果看到一个牛逼的精英怪
我首先干嘛呢
我要逃跑对吧
保命要紧
如果发现是个普通小怪干嘛
我要去进攻它
你如果按这个逻辑
你看这是一个很简单的一个bot的AI体系啊
你就可以这样把它recover
怎么去保密的地方
我们就展开了
对不对
这个地方他的就是你从这个就是啊解
就是解读这个这件事情呢
这个任务来讲的话
诶我会把它分成三个选项
第一个选项是说第一种可能性是说如果有药水
我优先使用药水
如果没有药水
我去找一个药水对吧
如果这个药水也找不到怎么办
我就用我的万万能药对吧
那接下来依次展开了
比如说我怎么样子去这个找一个坡式呢
那我首先的话去造一个
造一个的话就要找材料
要不要去造
但是呢如果我造不了怎么办
我去买
那我买的第一件事情干嘛呢
诶我要先去跑到那个npc store
怎么样
很好理解吧
就是其实这个s ti我觉得它设计的巧妙的地方
就是其实我拿着一颗behavior tr
跟一个这个怎么说呢
非游戏行业的同学去解释我想干什么的时候
很多时候大家会懵掉
但是HTR它已经简化到叫做
我觉得我跟一个就是啊就怎么说呢
这个中学生小学生去讲这个游戏是怎么设计的
他才能告诉我说我AI就这么设计了对吧
所以我觉得这个事情还挺牛逼的
已经一个一个一个点好
诶
当我有了这样的一个就是tn多man之后
接下来我干嘛
哎我要开始做规划了
做planning了
这个plan的过程其实刚才讲完之后
大家就会觉得已经不难了
对不对
那我首先的话呢根据现在的worst state
你不是有一个root task吗
那我实际上就可以根据你们的priority
我就知道咱们优先选一个我的go
就是我的当前的目标的这个task对吧
那第二件事情呢
就是哎我既然你有了目标的task
那我就从你的method开始
去把你所有的task开始去展开一层的展开
对不对
一直长到你的primitive开始
但这里面呢有一个细节来了
这个细节是特别容易犯错的
就是说其实我在这个展开的推演过程
这个过程呢是电光火石之间呢
就是我现在脑子中产生的一个概念
叫做我要去啊解读
那这个解读我现在想到了
说诶我就要去买这个这个解药
那买解药的时候
这时候我就需要去这个去找到那个NPC多
其实这里面的话呢
我的每一个premium task的话
它都会有一个effect
就是如果我这个任务完成了
假设成功了
我对这个世界的状态是不是有个修改
对不对
所以呢你会发现
如果你脑子中只是这样在展开
实际上你的这个对世界的修改它不会存出来
但是呢你接下来的计划就没法做
为什么呢
因为你比如说你去买到一个解药
实际上是你后面用解药这件事情的precondition
那你后面的这个计划过程就会失败
所以呢他在这里面有个细节
就是说他把worst day做了一个
在大脑中的一个拷贝
你可以想象成就是我把世界的状态变成一张
抄下来
放到另外一张草稿纸上
然后我脑子中就在推荐说
我如果按照你的这个HTN的这个计划
去展开的时候
我做的第一件事我找到那个NPC
那个shop可能会成功对吧
如果做完了他就成功了嘛
那我就可以找到那个NPC好
第二件事情就是好
我mp我已经在那个那个shop里面了
这个时候我开始进行买的新闻
买了新闻之后
我假设成功了之后
我就会把药水数量加一好
又是钥匙数量加一的话
那我就可以启动下面的使用药水这个操作
所以呢实际上他在做计划的时候
他会假设所有的action都会成功的
诶这个地方就有看了
对不对
大家会发现怎么可能呢
你这个比如说因为你这个计划做完之后
你真的执行
他可能需要几秒钟甚至是几分钟的时间啊
在这个几秒钟或几分钟的时间里面
会很多事情发生啊
对不对
但是呢他在计划的时候
他是假设一切一切成功的
接下来我们会讲到一个细节
叫做REPLANNING的话呢
他就在解决这个问题
所以此处呢大家暂且认为他所有的计划都能够
Task
都能不被成功地完成
那这样的话呢实际上就是说
但是呢我们在计划的时候也是会发现
就是说这个precondition他是没办法满足的
那怎么办
或者说啊
因为有些PREGNITION是整个世界的环境不允许
怎么办
那我只能返回一个force了
就计算机中间他钻钻钻钻钻到某一步
task说诶你要去买解药
你就必须比如说你要有一个坐席吧
他之后发现其实此时本人已经没有作息了
而那个时候NPC的那个那个那个商店
是在另外一个城市
你没有办法那个teleport
没有办法那个飞跃
那怎么办
那你就怂了呗
所以那这说明什么呢
他就把这个错误的信息一路往回返
一直就是只要错了
他就往回跳
跳了之后呢
如果发现每一次都没有更好的选择
他可以一路打回到这个root task的
打回到root task的时候
这时候说哦
那就意味着我的第一个task就是整个失败了嘛
那我就依次往下去走嘛
但这里面有个细节是什么呢
就是当我们的设计师去构建这个root的时候
有一个细节就是
千万千万要设置好足够鲁棒的default task
你千万不要让NPC不适合看
否则的话
你如果想的所有的task都是那么有挑战
那么有意义
有可能当世界的条件不满足的时候
你看到的NPC干嘛就傻站在那儿了
就是诶这时候是不是系统出了bug
其实系统没出bug
只是因为现在的很多环境变量并不满足
所以的话呢NPC没有任何输出了
告诉他该干什么了
所以一般来说我们会配一个什么
比如说default idol啊
比如NPC在那边实在没事干
干嘛
搔首弄姿啊
对不对
给你打打招呼
挥挥手啊
这个这就是很多我们在设计一个
好的游戏的时候要注意的一些细节好
那这样的话呢
其实当我们去这样的依次的去traverse
就是我们这时候当那个task不行的时候
我们去找下一个task
这样我们就依次循环做完
那到最后的话呢
实际上我们就会把整个这个数渲染
那个整个整个traverse1遍
那最后的话呢一般来讲
只要你设计师没有做坏的话
我们会输出一串的
我要完成的原子形的task
注意啊
到最后你HTN它实际上是有component task
和permit task构成
但是这棵树你traverse完之后就是按这种方算法
你整个便利完之后
形成你的这个那个你的这个task序列的话
它一定是一串premiere task
那这样他就依次执行完
在接下来的话下个什么呢
交给plan runner
就是说A计划执行者开始愉快地执行
我现在定好了这个这个计划了
英文中有个词叫sounds like plan对吧
听上去我们好像有个计划了
那我们就开干嘛
好
这个这个时候这里面举个案例吧
就是比如说还是刚才那个案例
你会发现就是我一开始去找解读
解读之后发现第一个use portion那个地方坏了
搞不定怎么办
我就要found a portion对吧
因为我现在没有portion好
那这个时候我就去看看能不能首先优先选择
能不能造一个破损
造一个破损的话呢
这时候我发现我的第一个message的话呢
是这个就是啊我就好
这个就是我去make a portion
这个事情我也失败了
因为我没有材料
那怎么办
我我选择了就是bia portion
那这样的话你看那个链路
最后它就形成了几个
最后输出的其实是BIOPPORTION
use portion那个task列表
就是你首先要去买一个portion
然后呢再去用这个portion
这个是一个极其简单的例子
如果刚才我讲的那个分解的话
你得先跑到NPC
那然后再怎么做一大堆很奇怪的事情对吧
跟他做一些很奇怪的对话
你才能完成
但是呢这不重要
这都是细节
你只要理解了这个HTN的这个基础结构的话
作为一个设计师
我们可以把这个东西变得无无比的复杂
所以这个呢就是HTI的一个基础的运作模型
那么其实呢当这个时候呢
我们就会依次的有了这个计划表之后
我们plan runner就会依次的去执行这个计划
但这里面有很重要的点
就是当我们在写这个东西的时候
你会发现诶我的这个这个task可能会失败
刚才我已经反复解释过了
就是说因为整个AI at它在游戏世界里面
游戏世界是个非常动态的对吧
AI体会对世界有很多的假设会执行
但是玩家也好
其他的AI也好
他们都对这个世界形成这样一个输入
大家听说过著名的三体理论
对不对
当这个世界的参与者
不再是单一的一个个体的时候
这个世界是个什么东西呢
它其实是个混沌系统
哎这里面我就讲游戏AI非常有意思的地方
就是说你可能每个AI的算法
是一个非常简单的算法
但是呢如果我给你放入足够多的AI
然后呢放在一起
我既是一个最简单的AI模型
其实整个这个系统的output它其实是不可预计的
诶这个很有意思了吧
所以说我觉得做游戏引擎做到后来
你真的有的时候会对这种
就是这种这种很玄学的东西很感兴趣
因为你会发现你真的在做世界的模拟
那真的就像我我有的时候比如说我做
我
因为我个人蛮喜欢AI这个东西嘛
就是做完一个AI之后
你会静静的看着你的AI互打互殴
你可以看一个小时到两个小时
真的这个这个大家如果有机会
你们自己做游戏的AI的时候
你就能体会到我讲的这个乐趣
就是你做了一个bot对吧
然后你就看那些bot在一起打架
你可以看一个小时
一点问题都没有
觉得很有意思
然后呢打着打看着看着就觉得不过瘾
就开始改它的参数
再让他们再打
直到这个这个这就有点像养蛊的感觉一样
所以其实呢就是说在这样一个混沌的KOS
这样一个系统里面的话呢
实际上你很多的task他可能都会失败的
那么这个失败的时候
那我们这个task
其实实际上的话就是他就会
我们认为整个这个计划就失败了
对不对
但这个时候就要启动我们很悲催的行为来
叫什么呢
叫REPLANNING
我们要重新计划了
所以的话呢一般replay一般是这么几件事
第一个就是呢哎我们的这个现在没有计划对吧
还有一个是什么呢
我当前的计划已经成功地执行完了
或者执行到一半我失败了
还有一个很重要的东西
这个东西其实也是arguable
就是说如果在我的主观意识里面
这个世界已经发生了一些改变
就是sensor告诉我说
诶比如说你现在做的所有的计划
是假设现在在游戏的前期没有
你比如说我方没有丢掉任何一个夺气点对吧
但是这个时候假设说我的
你现在做的所有的计划是什么
诶我要去抢一个补给点
去支撑这个这个A点的夺取
打个比方啊
但是这个时候呢
你突然发现世界的状态发生变化了
就是A点丢了
所有人都向B点去冲了
那怎么办
诶这个时候你的计划需要重新制定
所以这个也是很重要的一个细节
就是说就是其实我做的任何一个计划
你不能僵化的执行
就是我们经常讲就是我虽然永远是有计划
但是呢并不代表我会避
而就是闭目塞尔
就是不关心外面发生的事情
如果外面的情况就是大的格局
大的变量发生了变化的时候
我的计划必须要重新制定
所以REPLANNING
实际上是HTN网络的一个
非常重要的一个体系
就是很多系统做的好不好
其实REPLENTY这个东西影响非常大
好那讲到这儿的话
基本上我们把这个HTN的这个东西啊讲完了
那么HDN实际上呢
我认为就是说它是一个非常好的一个东西
就是它跟BT很像
我个人觉得是对BT一个非常好的抽象和总结
那么很容易让人去理解
然后呢
他非常方便的
让我们的设计师能规划一些长期性的这些行为
那更重要的一点是什么呢
就是说它执行效率其实比BT高
因为BT大家记得我上次讲过一个细节
就是BT他在每一次就是AI被唤醒tick的时候
他都要从root全部跑一遍对吧
实际上你会发现90%的时候
从root那边TK1边是没有意义的
因为它最后就是停在了那个节点
跟上一次tick没区别
上次那个action没做完
你这次还等着action做完
但是呢你去把BEAIREE
整个tick和一片那个事儿本身就非常的费
这个地方的话
我们自己做引擎是有血泪的教训的
就是说把那棵树整个traverse1片
它本身可能吃掉你70%到80的
这个计算的这个那个budget
那么实际上的话呢就是说HTN的话
他就很聪明
他就说哎除非世界发生改变对吧
除非那个你之前的那个task失效了
或者没做完
我这个HTI我就不用再算了
所以它其实是比那个就是比halo train更高效了
但是我在上节课也讲的就是比AI
却很多时候他们也会做一些优化
但这里面就不会再复述了
但是呢就是说我觉得
其实这个就是说HTN的话
它有它自己的一个缺点吧
就是说我认为就是第一个呢
他去配置很多的precondition
和他的这个condition和他的effect的时候
它实际上形成了一个
就是我们叫做一个逻辑链路
就是说我前面规划的动作
他对这个世界的改变
正好能够符合我后面的某一个动作
可能不是紧邻的
可能隔了几步的动作
它的正好的precondition
那么当我有这么多task
依次的在修改这个世界状态的时候
有可能你这个task本身啊
他很可能形成不了
但是呢设计师当你面对就是说几十个
上百个这样的一个primitive test10设计的时候
实际上很容易会出现一些小的错误
就是说诶实际上我的这个计划是没办法形成的
这样的话呢
其实说HTN的话呢
至少我自己会认为说
我们需要做一些静态检查工具
帮助设计师的话
能够及早的发现这样一个错误
就比如说很容易出现的一个错误
就是我设计了一个premiere task
但是我忘记了给它加上一些effect
结果当我这个HM跑起来的时候
这个任务老是生成不了诶
不是说好了吗
这个上一个任务执行完之后就要执行下个任务
但是呢他自己进行这种可行性检查的时候
他总是发现那个有个state的满足不了
所以他就跳过去了
所以这个事情就很麻烦对吧
那么包括呢
就是说对于一个长期的一些行为事件的时候
其实呢这个task呢就是你做了一个plan啊
这个plan他链路很长
其实很容易在中间fail掉了
那么你们想一想一个事情
就是说
假设我们在一个高度不确定性的一个环境里面
我们一个同学他特别的勤奋
他总是做他的这么比如说一年的规划对吧
每一次他会花一晚上时间写出一年规划
但是呢因为环境发生了变化
他每一次执行个不到呃
几天一个星期这个计划就失效了
他被迫又开始重新做计划了
那么从从他自己来讲的话
他很辛苦
很勤奋
对不对
总是在不停的更新他的计划
但是的话呢站在一个外人的角度
你有没有发现这个这个家伙的行为
是不是好像很不靠谱啊
今天说了
我要练成一个什么这个世界冠军的肌肉
明天说我要当游泳冠冠军
后天我要说我要做数学小能手对吧
因为一会儿大家觉得这个这个目标好
一会儿觉得那个目标好
那你会觉得他的行为就很怪异
所以说在一个高度不确定性的
这个环境里面的话呢
实际上HTN这个网络的话
如果你做的计划过过于长
过于缜密的话
反而会导致这种就是AI的行为
一种我可以称为叫震荡或者叫不稳定性吧
所以这个也是他HTN本身可能有的
这样的一个问题
好讲到这儿
我们H点讲完了
我们第一趴好
那接下来呢给大家讲个更有意思的东西了
叫go oriented action planning啊
这个呢就是基于目标的
这个就是action planning诶
这里面讲了一个planning这个词
大家对planning这个词怎么理解
刚才我们讲了planning叫计划对吧
这个地方的话呢
我觉得实际上它最好的一个一个翻译是什么呢
规划大家学过动态规划吗
我相信所有学过数据结构
学过算法的同学
提到这个规划这个词
是不是突然觉得背后这个汗毛一竖
因为规划问题
动态规划问题是个np hard问题对吧
几乎所有的算法神坑
都在这个动态规划问题里面
那么包括那确定性的规划还好
如果是加上一些随机变量的规划
那简直就是哎呀欲生欲死
所以呢唉这帮人就想着说哎我们不怕
我们算盘很牛逼
我们就是要把这个就是记忆目标的
我把你的action全部给你规划起来
所以这就是构图的这个这个算法的这个产生
那首先的话呢科普这个算法
实际上还是一个很很厉害的一个东西
像很多大作
比如像tom reader啊
刺客信条的奥德赛里面
他都是用GP这个结构
那么其实呢它实际上的话呢
他做出来的这个AI的行为啊
我个人觉得确实更会更加动态
而且更加具有环境的适应性
而且呢它并不需要我们的designer
做很多的这个预先的这些啊
action的这个梳理
待会我会讲到细节
为什么好
他构图的这个
它整个基础的算法结构是什么样子的
诶大家看这个图
为什么我刚才说我们讲HT n的时候
那个大家一定要记住这张图呢
因为你会发现GP的结构图
好像和HT n好像好像啊
对不对
你上面还有个sensor对世界的感知
然后呢我旁边有个什么呢
我旁边有个worst day
我主观上对这个世界的认知好
我旁边我中间的那个H原来的HTN多man
被换成了一个叫goat
就是那个我的目标集为AI said
我的动作集
然后呢这个时候我通过计算
我会产生我的plan对吧
然后呢生成我的plan之后
我plan就开始被执行一个plan renner
几乎你看是这个一母所生啊
事实上我一直高度怀疑
就是GP这个东西可能和那个HTM是一个
怎么说呢
是一个同门师兄弟吧
师兄和师弟的关系
确实这里面有很多的思想是很接近的
但是呢这里面接近的东西我就不讲
我就讲他们的区别诶
这里面很核心的三件事
就是在GP里面的话
第一个你有一个目标题
就是说我所有可以达成的目标
那大家会发现就是刚才我们在讲HTN的时候
不是讲说每一个task
它其实是个目标
你看我讲的时候经常不小心把task讲成目标
但是呢那个在HT里面的话
那个目标并没有显示的被定义出来
实际上是通过那棵树的结构
你能看出那个目标
所以那个目标是怎么样
那个目标是写在注释里面的
它还不是真正的目标
但是呢在这个GP里面的话
这个目标我们是要有非常严格的数学定义的
待会我会去讲
哎
你说就是说把所有AI能够完成的事情
我要把它定义成一个一个
可以用数学的方法表达的目标
第二个呢就是我的action
就是我能做很多的动作
这个听上去和刚才讲的那个premiere task
里面的诶
中间那action不是很接近
确实很像
但是有不同
那最后呢我们有一个叫规划问题
就是说如果我有了个目标之后
我怎么规划出一个序列的action去完成这个东西
这个里面这个planning不是做计划了
它其实是规划问题
待会儿会讲这个规划
这个地方还是有蛮多小坑的
那其实go set的话呢
在GP里面的话呢
我觉得有跟大家之前讲的那个HTM有相似的地方
比如说首先它扔到这个go set
这个里面的话
很像一个HTN的compound的那个task
它是有priority的
就是说你第一个塞进去的go诶是你最想达成的
然后第二个是你其思想达成的对吧
我形成了这样的一个prioritize
这样的序列
此处是不是很像诶
第二个呢
我每个go呢我一般会设一个precondition对吧
那为什么就是这个go我想优先达成呢
是因为当这个条件满足的时候
那我就肯定优先这购
比如说我最优先的go是什么
保命对吧
如果我发现我的第一个prefect
是说我现在中毒的话
那我最优先的go是解读
而不是杀死敌人
对不对
那么如果我发现我没有中毒的时候
我才会说诶旁边有没有敌人
我的第二个才是我去争取杀人得分啊
杀死敌人得分对吧
那依次展开了
所以说这个precondition就形成了一个有效的这个
prioritize的这样的一个一个一个序列
但是呢最不同的地方是什么
其实它每一个go
它是要用一系列的状态去定义的
什么意思
就是说我希望你做一系列动作
你做完这个动作之后
这个世界的以下比如说五个state要满足我的设定
比如说我希望比如说啊我的存活是true对吧
然后呢我现在中毒状态为false对吧
等等等等等等
他这个一般来讲的话呢
都会用一些布尔值去表达
因为你其他的比如说用比如说变量大于等于
或者一些其他的没有办法表达的变量的话
实际上比较复杂
所以这是GP系统一个很高的要求
但是我在解释
为什么这个东西它你要做的这么紧致
但其实你可以做的更广泛
但是它会给你的系统添加很多不必要的复杂度
所以这就是和前面无论是behavior tree也好
还是HT好
我认为这个本质的区别就是
在BEAIREE也好也好
在那个H也好
你的目标
很多时候是隐含在你的树状结构里面的
虽然我们认为你可以表达
但是你只是写在注释里面
但是在这个GP里面
这个算法里面的话
你的目标就是用一系列
你期望最后世界上的达成的状态
去定量的去表达的对吧
所以这是一个很核心的一个点
而且呢注意它不是一个单一的一个
世界状态的要求
它是一个就是connection of the states
或者说一个combination of the state
就是一个世界上
我我认为我目标状态的一个组合
那接下来的话呢就是说其实这里面举了个例子
就是说哎我如果用构图的方法去表达
我们的游戏AI的时候
刚才一样的例子就是说诶如果我发现我中毒了
我第一件事情我要我最高目标是要解读
如果这个时候我发现是个精英怪
我最高目标是什么呢
就是逃跑
如果我发现这个小怪干嘛
我要去攻击它对吧
那这个简单的就是用这个方法去表达了好
那么action set的话呢
跟那个primitive task非常的像
对不对
我每个action我首先有个precondition
因为只有pk肯定是满足我才能够去执行它
然后呢我做这个action的时候是我的动作
但是呢我最后的结果我还有一个affect your
这个世界状态的改变对吧
就是我对世界状态的毒和对世界状态的血
但是这里面加入了一个额外的东西是什么呢
就是cost
就同样
比如说因为在整个构图这个算法里面的话
我们不会有一个有一个树状结构
或者是图状结构
把所有的action串在一起对吧
我没有这个东西
那最后当我一个目标放在这的时候
我是选择a action这个方向去做呢
还是选择b action方向做呢
那是不是有一个好坏的评价
所以这个时候我们的设计师就起作用了
设计师会说你现在呢这个造草药
这个cost是最便宜的
但是呢你现在如果要去买草药
你要干嘛
你要徒步走到那个这个这个这个要那个那个NPC
商店那边去
要花很久
而且中途你可能会被会被冒出来的
这个怪怪物给打对吧
那他的cost是高的
所以这个地方就是设计师的一个经验输出
告诉你说这个action set到底是啊有没有作用
所以这里面就引入一个量叫cost
唉大家想想为什么地方要cos呢
因为想象一下我们几乎所有的动态规划问题
是不是都要考虑cost对吧
从最简单的最短路径来讲
不就是要希望我们的这个成本最低吗
cos最低吗
这个地方planning的这个词又被激活了一下
那其实呢我有了这个一组的整个的这个目标
对吧
我随便我我选一个最高优先级的
我又有很多的可选的动作集
接下来就看我怎么演出了呀对吧
那我有了目标
我怎么演出了
这个里面的话来去理解构图啊
其实有一个最简单的理解方法
就是想想我们人类是怎么思考的对吧
人类去达成一个目标的方法是什么样的
很少有人就是正确的做法
一定不是正向的推导
一定是叫什么叫以终为始
就是以你的目标倒着去推
我怎么来
比如说我将来就是要什么什么
这个这个这个什么成为社会精英
我要什么怎么怎么样
那怎么办
那我要成为社会精英
那我就得获得一份好工作
对不对
我要获得一份好工作
那我就得要读个好学校
对不对
我要读个好学校
我现在在学校里
我就得认真读书
对不对
我认真读书的话
那我怎么办
我就得需要这个先去图书馆找找几
找几本书来看
看起来对不对
那你看你会发现你
然后最后你的就你的最后的决定是说
OK我放下我手头正在打的游戏
赶快这个和这个这个合集
我的电脑跑到图书馆开始读书去了
就为了10年之后我能成为社会的精英对吧
那么但是的话呢
这个其实这就是人类的思维决策方式
而构图系统它最核心的一个点
也是这个就是我是倒着去计划我的每个action
比如说在这里面就是说我们的目标是什么
我中毒了
所以我要解读
那第一件事情是什么呢
我知道我要解读
我必须要做的动作是我要去喝解药
所以呢我的最后一个action一定是喝解药
对不对
好
我找到了喝解药这个action
那接下来的话我就会说你要喝解药
你得怎么办
你的首先你得有解药
对不对
那你有两个选择了
比如说你去喝那个万能药对吧
你也可以和专门的解毒药
OK好
这个action我也能找到
就是我要去获取一个这个解药水
好
我为了获取这个药水的话
我要干嘛
我要去先走到那边的一个NPC商店去买它对吧
所以说你看这样的一个gop planning
它是不是很像我们人类的倒叙的思考方式
这个就是它的算法的一个核心点好
那么接下来我们就想当我有了一个目标之后
大家注意啊
知识目标它很复杂
因为目标一般来讲都不是单一的state
那我这个时候呢就在我的整个action set里去寻找
那我先选择第一个
我先把我的GP的这个这个state就是我的gold
这个这个state和当前的设计是不state进行比较
你会发现有些state它已经满足了
那我不管它了
ok great我我成功了对吧
但是呢会有一些state不满足
那说明什么
说明我的这个go没有达成
那怎么办
我这个时候就会在整个的这个action set里面
去寻找哪一个action
它的precondition现在其实是能满足的
同时他的effect or
正好又能把我想要达成的那个state给他写过来
这个时候呢我就去找这样的state
那哦对是在这个地方
那么这个时候我就去找到这样的一个这个action
去满足他
但是呢你大家注意这名action就很有意思了
就是action他会把state改掉对吧
但是他会满足我的一些需求
但是呢这个action本身他可能本身要求也很高
他说我需要你的worst states的话
这个这个应该是下一步了
就是说我我需要
我要为了我为了执行这个action的话呢
我实际上还需要一些precondition
如果这些precondition本身不满足怎么办
我把它反向的加回到一个列表里面
这个列表是什么呢
我们叫做unsatisfied state
所以说其实我会构建一个堆栈
我把现在所有不满足的这些这个go
你们把词放进去
然后呢我选择了一个action
满足了你部分的这个stage之后
我会把它移出去
但是呢因为我为了完成这action的话呢
我又要需要这个action本身需要一些precondition
那我把这些这些state呢又加到这个stack里面
我的目标是什么呢
就是我要不停的去往后面加加加加这action
最后使得所有的这个这个这个unsatisfied
这个就是那个state stack的话呢全部清零
这其实就是我们的目标
这件事情讲起来有点抽象
但实际上的话呢
这也是GP系统最复杂的一个地方
就是说如果任何一个go它是个单一的state
然后呢每一个action呢
它都是一个单一的state的一个一个链路
比如说PREDICTATION只有一个
那我的那个factor只有一个的话呢
它其实就是一个很简单的图图的问题
对不对
我们只要沿着图一路寻找就可以了
但是的话它比较复杂的是什么呢
就是我的go本身是要五六个不同的state
然后呢我每个action的话
它可能有几个precondition
它的affection也会有几个
他这个东西最后怎么去解这个问题
这个地方的话实际上在我们在学习GP的时候
我们是踩了很大的坑的
就是哈哈我们争论了很久
而且也也在研究
那这里面我跟大家分享一个
就是我们对知识的理解
其实这个地方其实有点抽象
我们再讲一遍啊
这也是学构图特别容易踩的一个坑
就是首先的话呢我们选择一个go对吧
这个go的话是对这个世界我们的一个需求
OK那么跟接下来的话
我们会把这个go里面的所有的state
和世界的state进行比较
如果已经满足了
我们就不管它
但是对于那些没有满足
就这里环伺的部分
我会把它扔到一个
就是stock of unsatisfied的那个st
就是所有未满足的这些state的这样的一个
一个堆栈
我把它放进去好
这个时候呢我们就会比较第一个没有满足的state
我们去找有没有action
他的effect or正好是能满足我这个state
如果这件事情的话
假设我们找到了的话
那我们就假设我们这个planning的时候
我们就说那我们就选择这个action
那么好
那这样的话呢
我们就会在那个没有满足的这个C里面
把第一个那个state给它移掉
因为我以我的假设就是我执行这个action的时候
我就可以满足你这个条件了
对不对
但是呢假设这个action的话
它本身就需要一个PREGNITION
怎么办
哎我们就会把这个precondition的话呢
就是反向的再写回到没有满足的目标
就为了就这个解释
就是说我为了完成你的任务
所以我要做这个动作啊
但是呢我做这个动作又需要一个前提条件
这个前提下又变成了一个我需要满足的东西
所以这个stack of unsatisfied state的话
是一个一直动态维护的东西
那我最后核心规划的问题是什么呢
我要规划出一条路径
当你按照这些action一次去执行的时候
哎我最后会让这个ANCESTIFY的这个stay的话
这个站全部清空
当然了
我另外一个额外的非常
这个就是说过分的一个要求是
我还希望这些所有的action cost加在一起最小
这其实就是构图问题
算法中最核心的两个目标
我同时要达到
当然了
我优先肯定是能够完成你的目标对吧
在完成你的目标的前提下
我再去找代价尽可能少的目标
这就是一个动态规划问题了
好
所以这个地方呢如果大家理解的时候
大家就会理解下面这个很核心的一个算法了
就是说对于这个问题怎么求解对吧
其实大家仔细想这个问题求解起来非常的复杂
比如比如说我现在知道一个够了
对不对
那我这个够有五六个state
然后呢我就在整个的action set
就是我的动作空间里去寻找
那我假设有100个state对吧
我每走一步
我要展开100种可能性
然后呢再往下展开100个100个100个
大家想想看这个是不是疯掉了对吧
那这个就这就是为什么我们讲动态规划问题
它是个mp HT的问题
就是这一点
所以的话呢这里面有个非常重要的一个变换
就是说我们要把这个构图的问题啊
把它变换成一个图的问题
这个图构建起来怎么构建呢
就是大家会很自然的一个想法是什么
我们会把这些啊就是state
把一个state作为他的note
就是这是我要达成的目标对吧
那我的AI是什么
这里面就会讲一件事情
就是说其实这是购物系统非常巧妙的地方
他把state动作和cost构建了一个有效的图
这个图呢它的特点是什么
第一个讲它的node是什么
node就是我们的state的一个组合
注意啊
这里面最容易犯的一个错误
就是说大家会认为node表达的是EXCE不行的
它是一个node的组合
比如说我的优化的起点
比如说我的go就是我的起点
刚才讲了我们这个逆向了
对不对
所以我们的优化的起点是我们的目标
哎这个有点意思对吧
然后我优化的终点是什么呢
是我当前的state
所以呢在这个图里面的每一个node
它实际上是一组state的combination
就是比如说我的go里面
我最需要的那个五个状态都是true好
那把五个状态都是竖写进去好
接下来按照刚才的原则
我们假设他所有在这个状态下
在当前思想我能做的action
注意啊
不是所有的action都是有效的
为什么呢
有些action在当前这个倒叙的状态里面
它的PREGNITION是不能满足的
大家能理解吧
诶我把所有的可能的状态
我延长出这个所有可能做的这个action
变成它的一条条的边出去
那么这个action的话本身是有一个什么有个cost
就是它的distance
对不对好
但是你这个action如果做了之后
其实整个state就被修改了
对不对
它会产生一个新的state
哎我就新的state这个BC就在里边了
那么以此类推啊
实际上我可以根据我的目标
根据我的这个终点
我可以把整个action展开成一个巨大的一个图
而这个图的话
我们核心的任务是什么
是不是就是在这个图上去寻找一个从go
就是从你的目标到我们当前状态之间
一条最短的路径
那这个地方的话呢
如果这个图假设我们构建出来了
那这个动态规划问题
是不是变成了一个非常简单的一个
最短路径搜索问题
那这个问题我们的上节课讲过了
很简单啦
那我们就用这个大名鼎鼎的A星算法嘛对吧
那证明A星算法的话呢
它实际上就是说他是个heroic算法
它本身的话就是对于世界的探索
但是这里面的话呢其实有个小细节
就是诶我的heuristic part在哪里
比如说同样两个分支
我优先选择哪个
那这里面的话呢就是在GP的那个放算法中
他会说哎你就优先选择那个
就是假设你的这个current那个状态和
那个就是这个这个你的目标状态
和
你的这个就是说当前状态
就是最接近的那个状态
那如果往这边走的话
你会发现实际上是你的current state
就是跟current最接近的state
我就有优先认为给他一个那个权重
说那个权重给的比较高
那这样我的算法就会优先的往那个方向去倒
但是大家可以看出来
就是说A星算法它第一个能保证你
如果这条通路真的存在的话
它一定是能找得到的
但是呢它其实只是说约莫的可能是最近的路径
但并不能保证其实这种的不能保证最优路径啊
实际上我们认为是个好的东西
为什么呢
当这个世界的状态一直在变的时候
其实NPC他也不会永远做那个最优选择
因为就像一个人一样的
如果一个人他如果做所有的角色
他都是最优选择的话
你会不会觉得这个人像个机器人对吧
极度的冷血
极度的理性
这个人就觉得不好玩
其实我们在做游戏AI的时候
我们有时候也会这样
我们希望他有的时候会做一些很合理
但是看似很笨的啊
就是有点傻傻傻傻的
这样的角色会让这个行为看上去更natural一点
所以我觉得这就是GP这个算法
有的时候你会觉得诶
他的AI有的时让你觉得很惊艳
很活的一个原因
那么所以呢其实GP这个算法呢
我个人认为它其实跟NHTN其实是蛮接近的
但是的话呢它会让这个环境啊
就是让这个AIT的行为变得更加的动态
而且呢他第一次真正的把就是你的目标
和你的行为decoupling了分开来了
因为无论是从有限状态机也好
到这个behavior tree也好
甚至到HTN也好
其实啊我们的行为通过一个拓扑结构
本质上就锁死成了一个目标
但是购物系统的好处是什么呢
因为环境一直在变
即使是同一个目标
你会发现它的执行路径是完全不一样的
而且这个路径很多时候它会beyond
就超过我们的设计师的想象
所以有的时候你用go做的AI的话
他的行为有的时候会让设计师都觉得哇很精彩
他居然会这么干
当然了
那个所以的话呢包括它能规避
就是说HDN那个算法的话
有的说如果我们设计师数据没有配好的时候
他会陷入一些思索的状态
但是它的缺点呢其实啊也是很明显的
就是什么呢
我个人觉得其他的东西都不用讲
最核心的缺点是什么
就是他比较废啊对吧
大家想想刚才那个图的构建是不是很复杂对吧
然后的话呢也要做那个A星算法动态规划
其实那个东西是挺麻烦的
所以说这个他从计算量上的话
实际上是会大于这个传统的BT和HTN算吗
尤其是HT
我觉得HTN的效率还是蛮高的
所以第二个一个很大的一个挑战是什么呢
我不能讲是缺点
其实你可以认为是一个挑战
就是说当我们用GP的方法
真的把整个决策交给计算机的时候
事实上的话
我们需要对整个是游戏的这个状态
变成一个很定量的表达
如果你不你不去用一堆的布尔值
true force去表达游戏的状态的时候
实际上你的go是没办法定义的
那你所有的action也是没办法定义的
但是呢对于一个高度复杂的游戏来讲的话
这件事情其实很复杂
大家想象一下
我假设用购物系统
我做新机的时候
那心机里面这个现在这个状态哇
我的天呐
我怎么能用一堆true force表达我现在这个状态呢
我说实话我现在想想
我好像也没想明白该怎么做
所以说其实对于一些比较确定性比较高的游戏
比如说啊1V1对抗的时候
或者说几个小的AI对抗对吧
我每个关节的环境我大概知道
比如说我关注的变量就是我是不是残血啊
我是不是中毒了呀
对手的是个什么类型的怪物啊
那么这些比较确定性的这些量
我能够把它量化成布尔值的时候
我认为这件事情构图是个很好的东西
但是如果对一种比如像RTS这种超复杂的环境
多多维度的博弈的环境的话呢
其实构图它还还是会比较吃力
所以这也是就是说GP这个系统
你会发现它apply的游戏很多时候是一个单机的
就是说顺序性的
我刷关这种游戏好
这个时候呢也是传统的
我们的这个人工智能的方法
对吧好
那既然讲了这么多有趣的算法了
你又讲了他们的不足
那谁是这个世界的终极解决者呢
那就进入了我们今天课程这个最有趣的部分了
诶我们就哦不对
这个地方我跳了一下
这个地方我们课程中还在讲最有趣的部分之前
我们先讲一个啊
也是一个比较硬核的部分了
就是蒙特卡洛树research对吧
Mcs mc t s
那么这个蒙特卡罗方法的话呢
也是一个比较经典的游戏AI的方法
但这个地方蒙特卡罗吹search啊
其实它已经有一点跨界了
因为大家知道我今天课程要讲的
这个最有趣的东西应该是基于机器学习的方法
对吧
让我们的那个AI更加智能
但是诶这个蒙特卡拉吹测试的
它就介于这两者中间了
好哎呀
我已经讲了快一个小时了
已经一个小时10分钟
所以今天我觉得有可能会超过两个小时啊
那要不这样
同学们都先小小的休息一下
我先喝一口水
然后接下来下半场的话
就跟大家讲一下蒙特卡罗的方法
再讲一下我们的machine learning的方法
其实我会发现这两盘很有意思
就是说一个是讲这个阿尔法go的算法
一个是讲什么呢
一个是讲我们阿尔法star
就是一个是下围棋
一个是打星际怎么样
好玩吗
好那不管了
因为今天的课程实在是量太大了
所以我怀疑可能两个小时我搞不定了
那我们就那个还是抓紧时间跟大家讲
就蒙特卡罗的tracer是这个方法
那么首先的话呢
就是蒙特卡罗推测这个方法的话呢
实际上是非常了不起的一个一个算法了
就是说实际上他在很多很著名的系统
你都用到的
最大名鼎鼎的就是这个阿尔法go
就是这个我们做下围棋
把人类的这个就是所有的下围棋的
这个顶级高手
全部打翻了的这样的一个算法
说实话我我我小时候蛮喜欢下围棋的
然后我我觉得我我其实挺难受的
我觉得这么好的一个一个一个一个东西
居然被AI给毁掉了
现在围棋学围棋界
整个就大家士气很低迷对吧
那么另外一个的话呢
比如说像有一些呃大型的
比如turn base的游戏
比如说像全站他的几乎的最近的几座里面
基本上都是用摩托卡罗出色的方法
形成它的策略
其实后面我会讲
为什么像全战这样的游戏
它非常适合用这个蒙特卡的吹四个方法
那么蒙特卡罗这个方法呢
其实呃他其实他从逻辑上来讲
很像人思考的方法
就是我们怎么去下一个围棋的时候
我怎么去决定我的下一步做什么呢
哎这个地方我是不是稍微科普一下
围棋的规则啊
我们那个课程中有没有同学不会下围棋啊
啊我觉得可能是有的吧
我跟你讲围棋真的是世界上最神奇的一个C
就是包括我自己觉得就是如果大家想学棋类
我个人推荐啊
学两个习就可以了
一个是围棋
因为围棋的规则非常的简单
但是很精妙
第二个是什么呢
是国际象棋
但是很不幸的是
这两个象棋两个棋类全部被AI打败了对吧
但没关系
我们可以假设AI不存在
那么一切的规则其实非常简单
就是黑子白子轮流下
那么如果你只要你的子被对方围住了
然后呢你没有就没有
我们叫做气
你不能透气的时候
你的死就被人吃掉了
最后下到最后就看黑棋白棋谁占的空间
大规则其实非常的简单
基本上一一小页纸就讲完了
但是它的变化是精妙无穷的
就是这里面空间有多大呢
就是它的测试空间应该是三乘
一个380一次方这样的一个空间
就大概是十的170一次方
那么大的一个search space
就是以前呃好像我们的pony爸爸曾经说过一句话
他说你看我们的AI很厉害对吧
我们解决的问题比宇宙中的原子都要多
对他说的没错
因为宇宙中的原子数量是十的80次方
而围棋的变化是十的170一次方对吧
所以当然了
这没有那么玄学
实际上我哈哈
那个我们的AI确实能handle这样的一件事情
那么其实蒙特卡罗推测是
它的核心精髓是什么呢
就是说我在选择每一步下的好坏的时候
我在脑子中推演了几百种
上千种
我和对方在下棋的路数
最后选择一个我方胜利最大的方法
然后呢就说我再决定我的下一步怎么走
这个方法是非常像人类下棋的这个思路好
那么这个方法的源泉是什么呢
首先我们得这个不得不说这个我们的大神啊
就是那个费米对吧
他在研究研究这个这个这个就是new的核聚变
核衰变应该用的裂变的时候诶
他研研研用了这个方法
就是蒙特卡罗方法
就随机采样
蒙特卡罗的话
大家如果知道的话
就是欧洲的一个啊著名的赌城
我还去过那个地方
那个地方有个著名的F1赛道
特别有意思
就是那个城市就是那个一条主路
就是F1赛道
所以我一直在想象
就是如果F1的那个时候我在那边住的话
可以听到那种喧嚣的F1赛车的声音
但是据说那个地方消费非常高啊
大家没事别去
那简直不是我们老百姓能消费的东西
我觉得反正我我是敬而远之的
看看可以了
然后呢
那么蒙特卡洛吹测试这个方法呢
实际上是差不多在2006年左右吧
是有这位老哥
就瑞米这位老哥
他提出来的非常有意思的一件事情
就是说他是就是他其实这个工作不是他第一个
就是开创的
其实在之前有很多前任做了很多工作
但这个方法他第一个要解决的问题是什么呢
哎就是下围棋
就是因为实际上大家知道在人工智能领域里面
我们一直认为围棋是人工智能的圣杯
就是在很长一段时间里面
人工智能领域会认为围棋人工智能是搞不定的
因为就像他刚才讲了
他的search space太大了
他是这个三的这个380一次方
十的177次方
而国际象棋呢大概是十的50次方吧
所以当时深蓝去beat了
这个人类的国际象棋冠军的话
实际上是一个暴力搜索法
本质上是这么个做法
而这个就是围棋的话
因为变化量太大
围棋的AI在很长一段时间里面
连业余选手都打不过
而这位老哥的话呢
他是最早提出了用蒙特卡罗try search的这个方法
能够基本上达到了人类的业余选手的水平
当然到后面阿尔法go的时候
诶这个这个大力出奇迹对吧
最后能够干掉了人类的职业选手
那只是后话了
但是呢我们不得不承认
就是MCTS的话是一切的foundation
那么这也是我们可以看到
就是说
当你面对一个巨大无比困难的问题的时候
他是一个非常复杂的
这个一个推荐和和演算的问题的时候
其实你用随机的方法也能给你一个非常好的解
特别是对于复杂系统
那么其实蒙特卡罗推测是他的思想呢
实际上是非常简单的
就是说当我面对这样一个棋局的时候
我的白子要落的时候
其实我的棋谱会告诉我说我有以下
比如说五种甚至更多种的落子的地方
注意啊
这里面不是不to force落实
实际上它还是有一些基本规律的
就是说包括像alpha go的时候
他不是说每一步棋
他都要想380一个可能落子的点
那不得了
那个测试空间是实在太大了
而且它推荐出来的结果是没有什么意义的
所以它其实还是要follow1些落子的规则
那假设这里面我们规则告诉我们说
我们有以下几种落子的方法
那我到底落在哪儿呢
那人类的想法
他其实啊至少我们下棋的人会知道哎
你的脑子中会做很多的演算
我漏了这个字
对方会落什么字对吧
对方有几个选择
他这样选择的时候
我到底是主动被动的
但是像我这种非常菜鸡
菜鸡菜鸡的这个下棋的选手
我一般想到啊对方的两三步
我脑子中的这个memory已经不够使了
但是据说高手啊他可以下盲棋
下很多
那都是高手的非人类
我们不那我们大脑结构跟他不一样
那么当人类大脑中
其实推荐的过程真的就是过程好
那这个时候呢
其实我们就想办法怎么样的
用一种诶数学的方法表达它呢
对吧
你看我们在计算机里面
其实计算机里面我做所有的东西
我首先要建模
这里建模不是那个建3D模型啊
这个建模指的意思
就是我要把一个问题抽象成一个数学模型
因为计算机它只能处理数学模型
所以有的时候我们一直在讲
就是说为什么我们对宇宙那么感兴趣
我一直认为上帝他就是个他就是一个怎么说呢
我们的世界是去模拟出来的
那么上帝他就是什么
他是个数学家
所以他是用一个数学model represent了
我们整个这个universe
你的everything
因为确实是这样
就是说当我们在计算机里面
我们去表达一个东西的时候
我们能解决一个问题的时候
首先我们要把一个现实中一个非常模糊的问题
表达成一个定量的数学模型
所以大家很多同学我看过
就是在大学的时候参加过一个比赛
叫什么叫数学建模比赛对吧
我相信现在还有
我最近看到好多同学都参加了数学建模比赛
其实数学建模比赛啊
真的是一个非常非常好的training
因为这是大家未来在工作中
在系统中你们最需要的一种能力
就是我能抽象这个就是建模定量化处理论能力
那么对于刚才那个情况的话
我们就要对它进行建模
那首先的话呢我们要定义两个东西
一个叫什么呢
叫状态
一个叫动作诶
这个好像跟刚才讲的那个很像
对不对
但这里面在MCTS里面的话呢
状态和动作是有更精准的定义的
第一个状态是什么
就是我这场博弈的现在所有的子的分布
这个状态你可以认为我take a snapshot
就是我对整个局面take了一个快照对吧
那么action是什么呢
就是现状是这样了
唉我的动作比如说我要落子落在哪个点
那这个时候如果是围棋中的话
那就是XY坐标嘛对吧
我就落这个词嘛
那好那假设我现在有一个state
那我根据我不同的动作
我是不是就形成了这样一个连接关系对吧
那我就形成了这样一个
一个只有一个子节点的一棵树
那如果我有很多很多的这个动作的选择
我现在是这个state
就是起始的这个initial state
那我有十个不同的action可以选择对吧
那我这个数据可以展开好
我做了这个动作动作之后
对方有十种不同的action选择
我继续展开对吧
那这样你会把整个这个棋盘上可能发生的情况
就变成了一个巨大的空间
这个叫什么呢
叫state space
但这个我一直认为state space这个词不是特别的准确
我觉得更像是space train
因为在space很多时候我们只表示一个空间
就是所有的变量的可能性
但是这些state呢它不是一个就是只是支撑在那
它其实之间是有个拓扑结构的
这个拓扑结构是一个树状结构
所以我我我会觉得它可能是一个
就是更准确一点
所以我我在描述的时候
我故意加了一个叫AI tree structured state space
它是一个用tree structure去连接起来的一个state好
这其实就是我们的蒙特卡罗啊
这个算法就是或者说我们人在下围棋的时候
如果我有无限的算力对吧
我经常讲这个词
如果我有无限的算力
我有无限的内存
那很简单
你肯定下不过我为什么
因为我把所有的这个情况没落子的时候
全部展开了
那我就可以选择出来
这个我该走什么一步
我记得好像在博弈论
还是那个某一个理论里面做了个推演
他说对于所有的这种确定性规则的游戏的话
一般来讲它都有必胜策略的
好像是一个好像是个数学理论吧
但是就是因为这个search space过大了
所以呢我们没有办法完全对他的全搜索
所以我们打不出这种必胜策略
好像他是有这么一个说法
所以啊这个整个space的话
如果全展开的话非常的大
但是呢理论上他一定能给你最优的解
而这个就是说在这个蒙特卡罗算法里面呢
有一个细节是大家很容易会这个犯晕的
就是我构建了一个蒙特卡罗这个tree啊
它成本非常的高
对不对
那么但是的话呢
一个经典的蒙特卡洛吹测试方法的话
他根据当前的棋局的状态
他就开始重新的去构建这个蒙特卡罗的这个
train来进行整个search
这是大家很容易犯迷糊的
因为我到最后只是决定我的下一步走什么对吧
所以呢我只要去找我下一步的目标就可以了
但这个地方实际上呢啊如果你有足够大的内存
包括你不介意把算法写的足够复杂
实际上在两次蒙特卡罗的try searching之间的话
其实是可以reuse很多的node
但这里面就是
所以我们我们今天在课程给大家讲的是
最古典的蒙特卡洛树的推测试的这个方法
但实际上呢我在很多那个就是前沿的一些工作
包括很多的实践中
他会对MCTS进行很多的优化
但是呢我们今天大家先记住简单
就是每一次你的根节点就是你当前的状态
它是你的root
然后你就开始去探索所有的可能性
往后去展开
那所有的MCTS的核心是什么
就是我去探索这所有的可能性
我选择一个对我来讲最有利的一个做法好
那怎么怎么样判断对我有利呢
这里面我要首先给大家介绍一个概念
这个概念其实非常的有意思
叫什么呢
叫simulation模拟模拟这个词大家都很熟对吧
我就模拟这个一个什么世界的什么什么东西
但但在但是在蒙特卡罗的这个这个算法
你们这个模拟是什么呢
叫我要把这盘棋快速的下完
诶
这很有意思吧
就是比如说它的一次模拟的概念是什么呢
就是比如说现在局面已经是这样了
我决定在棋盘的左边
那个这个比如说第十七十九这个位置
我下一个词好
接下来的问题就是我要让这个就是计算机
快速的用一个相对合理的方法
它叫default policy
诶
把我的棋下完
然后告诉我说这次模拟大哥你赢了对吧
所以呢
这个模拟里面
其实有很多随机性的东西在里面的
而且呢它下的过程中呢
这里面有个细节
就是说它实际上不能够乱下的
它实际上是有一个就是下棋的基础的
这个操作手册
这个待会解释
但是呢它的一个假设是什么呢
就是说当我这个从下一步走的这个状态之后
我往下做足够多次的这样的一个模拟的时候
诶是不是好像如果我做了很多次模拟
我好像这一步都赢了
面都很大的话
这是不是一个很好的一个一个步骤呢
哎整个蒙特卡罗推测时的核心假设
其实就是基于这个假设
那么这里面的话呢就引入一个概念叫default policy
其实policy这个词在AI也好
在这个控制论也好
其实是一个很重要的一个理论
就是大家这个我待会儿给大家提到
就是待会我们不会讲那个machine learning
机器学习嘛
其实机器学习的很多基础概念
并不是来自于我们的这个计算机
也不是来自于我们的游戏引擎
是来自于什么呢
来自于机器人学
就机器人学他常年研究的几十年前
人家研究的就是这种控制理论
所以policy是什么呢
是一套操作的基础方法
举个例子
比如说我们今天下围棋的时候
所谓的default policy是什么呢
就是我预先输入电脑的
人类的可能是几百张上万张的棋谱
就是AI
他在这个时候就是看到你走了这一步之后
他直接从谱子里面掉出来说哦
因为你是这个局面
所以谱上告诉我要这么做对吧
这样的话就是它的好处是什么呢
就是他不用再去search了
它速度很快
第二个呢它的它的下棋的这个指点
其实相对来讲比较合理
第三个的话呢
它其实可以非常快速的从头下到尾
所以这个policy其实你可以认为就是一个策略
就是我一个缺省的策略
但是呢真正你去做这个比较复杂的
比如像像那个阿法go这样的东西的时候
其实在default policy里面有很多有意思的东西
比如说你是被捕的呢
还是你自己训练好的一个神经网络啊
这里面就很讲究
但这里面我们不展开
但是你可以解释成就
我就做一次SIMATION
从头做到尾
那么最后他告诉我说
如果你走了这一步
我给你随机模拟完
我给你模拟完之后
我告诉你说这这一次模拟中诶
我到底是赢了输了
但这里面注意
有一个有一个概念上很容易混淆的地方
就是说我这一次模拟了成功了
比如说我赢了并不代表我就一定会赢
大家知道吗
它只是代表了
因为你知道就是这个在这个就是围棋的这个
树状展开的时候
它有无数种可能性对吧
但后来他的数字就大的惊人
所以它只是中间一个很小的一条链路
他表示我赢了
所以你再看蒙特卡罗
这个tracer是MCTS的
这个论文中的话
你经常会发现就是模拟它用一条小这个不折线
像条小蛇一样
就表示说那个就是一次探索而已
并不代表我这个节点下面的所有的state space
它都是成功的
哎这就是模拟的一个核心的点好
那我怎么去判断我现在这个这一步
下一步走的到底是好坏呢
诶它这里面就引入了一个非常定量的东西
叫一个是Q是什么呢
就是从我这个点出发
我做的
比如说先讲吧
就是说从我这点出发
我到底做了多少次模拟
比如说我做了100次对吧
那好那我的N就是100
那我这100次模拟完之后
到底有几次我下赢了呢
哎我就有个Q
那可能是Q是50或者是这个60
那实际上我们通过Q除以N的话
我们是不是就可以算出来说我这个state
我的成功率是多少对吧
所以说这一对pair就是Q和N的话
是蒙特卡罗MCTS算法的一个
很核心的一个数值
后面几乎所有的东西都需与它展开
那么好
那我们既然知道一个C的好坏的时候
我们其实在每一次进行模拟的时候
比如说我找到当前这个绿色的那个节点诶
我对它进行一次模拟的时候
假设这次模拟诶我得到的结果他是失败了
那是不是我只在修改这个节点的
他自己的这个QN值呢
唉其实不是
这里面有一个很重要的概念叫什么呢
叫back propagation
反向传导
那因为什么呢
因为你这个节点
你说我自己的这次simulation
我输了棋对吧
所以我N你要加一我的Q的话要加零对吧
我变了
同时呢你的父亲那个节点实际上也跟那边
为什么呢
站在他的立场上看
它确实又等于又多做了一次模拟
对不对
所以呢你的父节点
所有的数值也依次的往上去调整
就是Q也往上加
N往上加
所以这些数值要往上去propagation
这样的话当你做了足够多次模拟的时候
你会发现就是比如说你做了这个1000次模拟吧
那那个root节点上就会显示说诶
我当前是1000次模拟
然后呢我经过无数次分支的话
我发现我的我我当前这个状态
我的肾区率可能是五五开
比如说是500
一杠1000诶
我接下来有我有七部选七种不同的选择
对不对
我七种选择里面
比如第一种选择
我模拟了这个100次
我的胜率是多少呢
比如说70
另外一个节点呢
我可能是模拟了这个一百两百次
我的胜率是多少呢
是170多对吧
我这个Q也大
N也大
但是我会解释这两大有什么好处
所以其实你整个模拟做完之后
你会发现你对整个这个state space的话
没所有你探索过的这些state
他都有这样的一个Q和N值
告诉你说我探索了多少次诶
我的是我胜了多少次
这个数值很关键
那其实呢你有了这样一个基础的
就是SIMATION是什么
这个就是说那个我怎么去evaluate
这个这样的一个节点
那包括怎么做back back propagation
其实这个时候我们就可以跟大家讲MCTS
它基础的这个迭代步骤步骤了
因为所以我在讲MCT书的时候
他上来就给你讲框架
其实很多人看了这个就会觉得很晕
这个selection到底是什么
expansion是什么对吧
然后呢simulation是什么
然后back propagation是什么
那现在有了这个概念
就是大家可以知道
其实我们在MCTS的话
它实际上是一个一直在做的这个循环
它首先选择一个最有可能
因为你这时候走到一半
你这个数已经展开来了嘛对吧
但是它展开了可能就有几十个节点
或者是只有啊那个几个节点
这个时候呢
我先选择一个最有希望
且没有被完全展开的节点
也就是没有完全展
就是所有的可能性都没有完全展开完
接下来呢我要对它进行展开一下
再加一个新的探索
好新的探索之后干嘛呢
我要做一次simulation
看看这个探索的方向到底是好还是坏对吧
最后得出一个结果之后
哎我把这个数据再反向的property回去
把所有的数据就全部更新一遍
这就是mc ts的话呢一次的这个迭代
那么它就会这样一直迭代下去
一直迭代下去
那他什么时候停呢
我待会再讲
但是呢这就是MCTS的核心好
接下来的话呢给大家讲拿一个具体的案例
就是拿一个围棋的案例跟大家讲一下好
那么其实的话呢就是说这样的一个逻辑
按照mt s的话
你会发现你要展开的这个state space是无限大的
这个实际上是啊
大家可以想象这是一个围棋里面
大家看到这个空间有多大对吧
你想想看这才推荐的几部啊
我要是往下一直推荐下去的话
这个内存也不行了啊
算力也不行了
对不对
那MCS它的巧妙之处就在解决这个问题好
首先的话呢我们要定义一下
什么叫做可以被扩张的node
就expable node
它本质上讲的是说这个node
它所有的可能性并没有被重进
也就是说啊我这个note下面我下一步可以走
其实按照七步告诉我可以走十步或者走20步
20种选择
但是呢我现在只试了
比如说十种
那意味着的话另外十种没有被探索
那这个note呢它就是一个expment node
好
那我拿到一个这个就是状态
当前的状态的时候
其实我随着一次一次的迭代
我会慢慢的把这个树啊给扩张开来
那这个时候呢
但这里面有一个非常有意思的一个点
就是说我们每一次选择一个点
从哪开始探索
那么其实有两种策略
选择
一种叫exploitation
什么呢叫开发
一种叫exploration探索诶
这个听上去是不是这个好像有点
这个就是奇怪对吧
但这其实是在整个是那个深度学习
那个就是machine learning
包括像MCTS里面的话
一个很关键的一个概念
就是就是说我在进行探索的时候
我是优先去找那个胜率最高的点
我去探索它
还是优先去探索那些我没有探索过的点
哎大家觉得有没有意思
其实你这个东西听上去有点抽象对吧
但实际上的话呢在我们的真实生活中
这个东西是很常见的
比如说同学们看我们每天都在决策
对不对
比如说我今天决定吃什么
有些人策略是说我希望我去花了这笔钱
我得到的这个享受一定是确定性的
那我的选择是什么
一定要去我最喜欢且最熟悉的餐馆
我反复验证
反复吃那个地方肯定都是最好的对吧
有些人就他就是这个倾向
就是他叫exploitation
就是说开发型的选手
那么还有一类选手是什么呢
它叫exploration
我是探索型选手
就是我总是会逼着自己这个餐馆
我也不知道好不好吃
但是呢因为我没有吃过
所以我就冒着一次这个砸锅的风险
我也要去吃它一顿
万一它好吃呢
对不对
那其实我们人生的很多选择
就是在这个开发和探索之间做一个balance
那么反应到这个数值上
你会发现就是说如果是exploitation的话呢
我会优先选择什么呢
第一个这个地方访问的次数足够多
就是模拟的次数足够多
且胜率最高的那个点对吧
那我很多时候就选一个比首先N要比较大
同时呢我的Q和N的话比值也比较高
那么如果我是一个探索型选手呢
我就会优先选择那种叫做哎
我的这个就是N的那个数值比较小
我就是去给他一个相对高的权重
所以其实整个MCTS算法的话
他在这中间找一个平衡好
那现在的话呢就是说这个探索节点的选择
其实有一个很著名的理论叫USB理论
这个叫apple confidence bts
这个其实是一个很好的一个
一个一个数学工具啊
就是说啊它实际上叫上肢性空间
什么意思呢
就是说我对一个随机的世界进行采样的时候
如果我的我已经采来的一些数值了
说这个概率
比如说他一直这样分布
但是因为我采样的数数量特别特别少
我并不认为这时候我采来的数值是偏低的
是因为它真的低
很可能只是因为我采样的数量不够
不够不够不够多
所以呢他有一套数学方法
比如说你满足了我们的大数定理
或者满足我的高斯分布对吧
大数据基本已经满足高斯分布
那这个时候我可以有一套数学方法告诉你说
这个它的上肢性空间
就是说它的大概能大到什么样子
我有个方法
这个方法这个工固定理呢其实本身很复杂
但是呢在我们的这个就是
就是蒙特卡罗这个方法里面的话呢
其实它很简单很纯朴
第一个我优先选择是什么呢
还是开发
就是说你如果Q和N的值比较高
比值比较高的话
说明你的胜率比较高对吧
所以Q除N是我第一个考量的点
那么这就是满足你的开发的一部分
那么这里面我们就以那个建那个节点为例啊
但是我会跟你的父节点的整个次数进行比较
如果发现你的那个你的复节点
说我已经完成了100次的探索
但是呢我自己发现我只有两次和三次
那他又做了个公式
就是取了一个自然对数的
你的这个附节点的访问次数
产生二
除上一个你的这个这个你自己访问次数诶
我就相当于对他的这个置信空间
给出了一个up bd
这里面的话
如果这里面没有一个那个常数C啊
它其实是一个相对比较严格的数学定理对吧
假设你的随机变量永远在零一之间波动
我做了几次采样之后
我算出了你的这个你采样玩家的期望
假设是比如说0.7
但是因为你采样数量足够小
那么你的附近电采样那个你的更大
更上一个信号系统
采用那个次数很高
那我知道你可能这个数值你往上跑的时候
可能性
但是呢哎我们搞游戏引擎的人
或做一个这个计算机开发的人
其实很多时候我们是hack的对吧
那我们会怎么办呢
我们会在前面加个C这个常数
这个世纪精妙就精妙在这个C这个地方
就是说如果你希望你的这个蒙特卡罗的策略
更加的aggressive一点
就是更多的我要去探索的话
你就把C给的大那么一点点对吧
那就意味着什么那些被访问比较少的那些节点
它就会更大的可能性被这个select被选中
如果你希望我的这个策略更保守一点的话
我就把C给的小那么一点点
你看此处就有hack了对吧
那没关系
但是呢其实这就是为什么我有时候开玩笑
我就想说做这个做这个人工智能
有的时候跟炼丹一样
就是说你要是很多地方需要上手
根据自己的scenario去调
但是呢他的基础思想还是蛮成立的
就是说它实际上是做好了这样的一个平衡
那我们有了这个USB算法的话呢
其实我们就可以进行selection了
就是说当我这个每一次MCST的话
MCTS的话啊
不好意思
这里我给大家讲
我每次讲MCTS主要讲的方便
MCTS就是蒙特卡罗ree search对吧
这个简称这样讲起来比较简单一点
就MCT的话呢
他再去selecting我下一个要探索的节点的时候
实际上就是用这个USB形成的
这样的一个这样的一个一个一个数值进行比较
它具体算法的话呢
第一步是首先你每一次啊
就是你每一次整个这套迭代做完之后诶
你下一次再找新的一个节点去探索的时候
一定要从root开始
注意啊
这个是这个细节
很有意思
你一定要从root开始
然后呢你先比较你的第一圈的
你的所有的这个child notes
然后呢
你去看第一个他们的USB的值到底怎么样了对吧
那USB的值最大的那个
你就会作为你的下一个探索的方向
好
你再去问他所有的这个节点的这个它的子节点
你就往下走
一直走到什么呢
走到第一个可以
Expable
就是说没有被完全探索过的这个啊
没有没有没完全展开过的这个节点
其实这里面不叫探索
应该叫expand的这个节点
找到那个节点的时候
你就把那个点作为你的current
就作为你的select node去展开
这个地方其实有点抽象了
就是说所以我我我我我们内部在讨论的时候
我们在想这个MCDS让大家怎么去理解它
最好的一个类比是什么呢
我讲了一个非常不科学的说法
我说这感觉像是个广度优先搜索对吧
只是我这个数的数据一直在变
但是我每一次选择下一个要展开的探索的时候
我还是从根节点一次一次的很公平的比较
我所有的child对吧
我的child如果我选中它
我觉得它诶本身是USB值最高的时候
我再去钻下去
他找他的这个子节点
那这个大家会说
那我的假设我的child已经被封了
expend就完全被展开了
那我会不会就死掉了呢
实际上是不会
为什么呢
大家想象一下像阿尔法go的这种情况对吧
这个十的177次方
就我们那么点可怜的计算机内存对吧
你把这个计算机算爆了
任何一个分支下去
其实你都是不可能探索完的
大家发现这个事情是很有意思对吧
所以的话呢这个时候我一定能找到一个
就是没有被完全探索过的这样的一个节点
按这个算法
大家放心
这个肯定能找得到的好
那这个时候呢我们对它进行所有的可能的
就对它进行一次探索
这里面有个细节
就是说其实呢你可以选择我从select node
我只往外去expand1种可能性
也可以expand1组可能性
这都是可以的
但是我一如果你真的算力允许的话
我觉得探索一种可能性可能会好一点
但是呢这就意味着什么呢
每一种可能性诶
你要是不是要做一次simulation呢对吧
你的内存消耗这个快速增加速度也会更快
对不对
那但是呢这个你会让你这棵树更加的balance对吧
那这个这个探索这个expand我就做完了
好expansion做完之后呢
接下来我们对于接下来我要尝试的
落子的这些方向之后
我每一个做它的一个simulation
这里面大家看到我们画的那个小波浪号对吧
那我假设从这个点select
红色的那个select那个state去出发
我给出了三种探索的这个方向之后哎
做三次simulation
那比如说第一次submit的结果是我们输了
第二种semi
结果呢是我们赢了
第三个
我们输了
那这个时候我们会把它的输赢的这个数值
就是它的每一个节点的Q值和N值
一层层的往上去传递
大家仔细比较一下这两分数的点的数值
你发现没有
就是A比如说你现在select node
现在是零和一
就是这个这个点之前是被探索过一次的
他是零对吧
它它也失败了
但这个时候它就变成什么呢
零要加上个加上个一
它就变成了一了
而它的N值的话
以前是一
现在加上个三
因为你探索四次三次嘛
就是要加上个三
其实以从他网上去找它的附件点
每个节点的Q值都是加一
N值就是加三
所以整个竖的这一趴的
这条链路的数值全部被更新了
那你就这样呢就不停的去探索啊
探索啊探索你每一次探索
你本质上就是进行一次有效的
蒙特卡罗的simulation
但是这件事情你能不能一直做下去
实际上是可以一直做下去
只要你的那个state space足够大对吧
现在我讲了
如果你想把围棋的state space探索关的话
那我相信把全世界的计算机加在一起
可能都不够
那所以呢你就必须要停止
那怎么去停止呢
所以他的这种探索呢
会有一个就是这个bug的预算
比如说你的内存
因为这个数越变越大
越变越大
内存会炸掉对吧
那内存超过了一定的限额
我们就开始不探索了
或者是什么呢
就是说哎我的simulation的次数
比如说我规定好每一次对于每一步的思考
我最多simulation一千一千次对吧
就是说我脑子中推荐1000次
把这个棋下完的情况
你想这个计算量其实并不小
所以说其实你用蒙特卡罗推荐的方法去做这种
比如像围棋这种复杂运算的话
它的计算量还是惊人的
就是说它的内存消耗量也很大
而且它计算量也是惊人的
那么好
你设定一个competition的时间啊
或者是那个simulation的次数
反正whatever
你只要你喜欢
你就让这个蒙特卡罗的这个搜索就整个诶停掉
停掉之后你会得到什么东西呢
诶你会得到这样的一棵树
这棵树那时候已经很大了
接下来你要做的事情是什么呢
大家记得我们讲过蒙特卡洛吹search的话呢
它它的根节点就是你当前的整个棋盘的状态
这个状态大概率是你的对手下给你的
对不对
你这时候你其实你的选择只有一个
就是我的下一步走什么
那你的下一步是什么
是不是就是你的所有从根节点下来的第一个
第一环的子节点
其实其他下面下面展开的那些东西
对你都是没有用处的
对不对
诶这个地方就很有意思
对吧好
这个时候有意思的地方
黑科技就来了
就是说那我现在已经算已经测试过1000次了
那我接下来有十步可行的方案
那我到底选哪一步呢
这里面就这个就开始展开了
我们的各种玄学的东西来了
就是你个人所好了
比如说我可以选择这个就是max child
什么意思
就是我最好的孩子什么
就是我的Q值最高
就是从我这一科分支走下去
我剩的盘数最多对吧
这个听上去好像有点道理
对不对
诶但是呢这个地方就有个问题了
就是你Q值是高
但是你甲是N的很多呢
比如说你这个直接点对吧
被测试了100次
但你Q值是最高
你你最后达到了
比如说呃55次
但另外一个老哥他比如说测了80次
但人家的胜率是赢了70盘
那你到底你这个选这个50次啊
不是40版吧
那假设你这个是不是选的就有问题
哎另外一种策略叫什么叫robust child
就是说最多被访问的子节点
我认为是最鲁莽的
也不是最充分测试过了
那大家就觉得很奇怪的说
哎不最直觉的一个比较不是应该是Q比N嘛
就是我的胜胜利值对不对
但是的话你为什么说你敢选robustness
这里面其实就隐含了一个小细节
就是说大家发现没有
刚才我在每一次selection的时候
我其实不是随机展开的
我是用一个UCB算法对吧
或者那个也叫UCT算法
就是你用UCB的这个公式去做research
有的人也有人也叫UT
实际上他已经综合考虑的
你的Q和N的这个比值
所以呢一般来讲你被反复的试的那个节点
其实说明在整个前面数的这个展开过程中
他一直都被认为是很有这个希望的一个节点
所以访问次数本身
也代表了这个节点本身的靠谱程度
诶这个节点也是靠谱的
而且因为它simulation的次数足够多
其实它很robust
有的时候你单纯按Q值其实不一定考诶
那另外一个人就说哎呀你们两个就别吵了对吧
到底是Q值大还是N值大
是这个谁说了算呢
对不对
我的要求是最高的
就是Q值和N值都要大对吧
我要找到那个最大的Q值
最大的N值那个节点
那个节点才是我要走的步骤
你看这个这个就是小孩子做选择
成年人什么都要哎
这个事情其实是有道理的
但我自己也认为
就是如果你要做MCTS的话
那这个这个这个max robust child
一定是最好的选择
但是他就说了
那这个大哥
你这个跑完之后内存都吃光了对吧
那我这个这个已经没有了
这个这个找不到这个节点怎么办
诶他说我不管
如果你发现现在没有一个你直播的那一环的
child那个note满足我的需求怎么办
再继续跑
跑到这个节点出现为止
你看很不讲道理对吧
但是呢诶他这个方法确实是个方法
那当然了
还有最后一种方法就是比较折中了
就是其实我们不是有这个USB吗
哎我们这时候把它反过来搞
叫LCB上刚才讲的叫上肢性区间
对不对
现在我们讲我们来设计一个叫下肢性虚线
什么意思呢
就是说我综合考虑
第一个你的胜率就是Q除上N肯定要考虑
对不对
第二个我还考虑一件事
就是说如果你的采样次数不够大
那我要给你一个下调
所以这个时候你看那个公式刚才是加号
这时候变成减号
意思就是说
那你采样次数高的那个那个那个节点的话
他在这个时候它的优势就会大一点
唉这个其实是非常有意思的一件事情
但这里面老老问题又来了
这个C怎么设置
它又是个玄学问题对吧
但其实你会认为就是说
实际上这个这个secure chat
他用的LCB的这个公式的话呢
是把max child和robot chat结合在一起
考虑了
给了一个神奇的数学变化
再加上了一个权重
两个都解决了
所以这其实呢是一个
就是我觉得在大家在写蒙特卡洛
TRISHA的时候呢
会自己根据自己的萝卜白菜各有所爱对吧
你自己去试一下
看哪个更靠谱
你选哪个
然后你也不用长篇累牍的向别人证明
你这个东西是有道理的
反正只要work了就可以了
所以呢其实讲到这MCTS就讲完了
那么我觉得MTTVS它有个好处是什么呢
它会让整个A镜的行为啊还是满灵活灵动的
因为大家知道这里面是有随机数的好吧
其实只要有随机数知识的这个事情
这个世界就开始变得有趣了
对不对
然后呢就是说agent的这个决策呢
基本上是自己决策的
实际上你会发现就是一个你用MCTS设置的
一个这个AI的行为啊
其实已经超出了设计师的想象了
因为就像阿尔法狗样
下到最后人类已经下不明白了对吧
他就不知道他为什么会这么下了
那么其实呢
就是说我们对于一些非常复杂的测试
space的问题我都能解决
那么它的缺点呢
其实就是说啊对于一些比较复杂的游戏的情况
你其实很难那么精确地去表达
他到底是赢还是输
而且呢你很难精确的定义这件事情
我做了之后对这个世界的影响
所以的话呢
其实而且呢它本身的计算复杂度很高
那这个答案从我的这个算法描述中能看得出来
对不对
那么这里面我特别想多说一句
就是MCTS我自己啊对他的理解
就是说我不认为它能够适合所有的游戏类型
就比如说比如说今天我做一个啊MOBA游戏对吧
我去做用它MCTSMOA
游戏的这个这个AI的时候
如果直接硬做的话
其实是有问题的
我必须要对世界进行一个转换
那么实际上当然也有人用MCS做那个
有木板游戏的
你们的AI包括我们像一些回合制的战斗游戏
我自己的感觉
就是说如果这个游戏它是一个turn base
就是说是你一下我一下的这样游戏
第二个呢
他每一个动作
他的就是输出和结果是非常明确的
比如说我们假设这个回合制战斗游戏
那么我输出一个技能
那么我可以精准的计算出来
对方会被我打掉多少多少的血对吧
我自己会改变什么一个状态
所以它就像下棋一样的
就是你一下我一下嘛
那这种情况下
我觉得MCT其实是一个很好的框架
但是如果我们在做一些更high level的一些
就是更复杂的一些游戏环境的时候的话
那实际上你会发现
就是你不能够纯用MCTS了
你实际上是把MCT和比特吹啊
或者是GP啊
或者是HTN呢
大家结合在一起用
那么其实到最后你可能下面会放一个S就
有限状态机都是有可能的对吧
所以这个呢哈实际上是啊
我觉得就是大家真的在用它的时候
一定要把每一种算法放到他合适的地方
所以我们这里面举的几个案例的话
我自己个人是我能理解的
比如说我非常的理解
就是比如像全站里面我用MCTS能做什么
比如说我要做这个大世界上各个NPC的事例对吧
那些那个那些领主
那些君主
他看这个世界不就是我这个时候该刨冰
我这个时候该去宫里的一座城
还是跟你结盟吗
对他来讲就是我可以选择的action嘛
那每个省城的结果我其实是比较好的去估算嘛
所以他其实也是个turn base的游戏嘛
大家如果玩过旋转就知道
那这个它的战斗是实时的
但是呢他大世界的策略真的就是turn based对吧
所以这也是我个人对MC的理解好